Just, just, just paint it.
Almost heaven.
Older Twitch chat.
All these emotes.
Wondering how to spell that.
Now we're older.
Everyone's moved on.
But I remember Twitch chat.
From those days that are gone.
Twitch emotes.
From long ago.
Made you feel.
You're not alone.
Cappapog jam.
Keep a forehead.
Bible thumb.
Twitch emotes.
I remember.
Typing dance game.
Forehead swift rage.
PJ salt and fail fish.
Life was easy.
Spamming all the time.
TOS was nowhere.
So everyone's feeling fine.
Twitch emotes.
From long ago.
Made you feel.
You're not alone.
Cappapog jam.
Keep a forehead.
Bible thumb.
Twitch emotes.
Still hear his bark.
From the morning hour he calls me.
This doggy emote reminds me.
Of a time far away.
Looking at a chat I get a feeling.
That I miss emotes from yesterday.
Yesterday.
Twitch emotes.
From long ago.
Made you feel.
You're not alone.
Cappapog jam.
Cappapog.
Bible thumb.
Twitch emotes.
Keep a forehead.
Bible thumb.
Twitch emotes.
So.
Auf geht's.
Bashen, alter, bashen.
Ihr müsst mal gucken, ob ich irgendwie rumspacke, was den Sound angeht.
Weil ich hab letztens meine Streams angehört.
Und hab festgestellt, dass ich manchmal, wenn was ist, dass ich bisschen übersteuere.
Und deswegen hab ich jetzt mal ein Compressor eingeschaltet.
Also sprich, egal, ich kann jetzt hier voll reinschreien oder so.
Und es wird nicht lauter.
Also.
Nur bis zu einem gewissen Punkt.
Auf der anderen Seite sollte man...
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Ich hab übrigens keine Ahnung, was ich da eingestellt hab.
Mir gibt das Sinn, was ich da eingestellt hab.
Ich hab da keinen Plassen Schimmer von Audiozeug.
Ich hab das aus irgendeinem Forenbeitrag oder so.
Ja.
Keine Ahnung.
Hublull.
Also keine Ahnung, was das macht.
Der älteste Stream ist vor zwei Monaten.
Ne.
Wir haben, im Archiv haben wir alle Streams...
Ich hab hier doch grad den Chat gepostet.
Im Archiv haben wir alle Streams.
Bis 2000.
Bis irgendwie Ende 2007 oder so.
Guck.
Wubblords.tv.
Da.
Wir gehst jetzt auf Archiv.
Oder wie die coolen Leute natürlich sagen würden, Archive.
Archiv sagt ja keiner mehr. Ist ja Archive.
Und dann kannst du dir alles angucken.
Von 2007.
September 2007.
2007.
Siehst du, dass ich da sogar mal ein bisschen Overwatch gespielt hab.
Und KS, ich hab Overwatch gespielt.
Vier Stunden.
Ich hab allen Ernstes vier Stunden Overwatch gespielt, das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Wie hab ich das denn ausgehalten?
Wie hab ich das ausgehalten?
Das versteh ich nicht, ja.
Ja, na gut.
In Ordnung, na.
Sag mal, kann das sein, dass der Kompressor komische Dinger macht?
Also sprich, wenn ich ne gewisse Zeit laut rede.
Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Ne, ist kein Unterschied. Erinnert sich nix.
Also, die Sache ist halt die, wenn ich das ausschalte, übersteuer ich manchmal.
Und das sackt. Guck, ich zeig's euch mal.
Ich das ausschalte und ich mach jetzt.
Oder ich huste oder so.
Verrecken. Dann übersteuer das Ganze.
Und es sackt. Auf der anderen Seite.
Eigentlich kann ich noch so laut rumschreien, wie ich will und übersteuer nicht.
Eigentlich könnte ich den Kompressor auch auslassen.
Na gut, dann lass ich den Kompressor mal aus, ist wurscht.
So, also Leute.
Ich hab da was gefunden. Ich zeig euch mal was.
Aber jetzt muss ich erstmal gucken, weil im Chat gibt's Questions.
Erstmal haben wir irgendwie nen Sub gehabt, den hab ich übersehen. Kann das sein?
Und zwar.
Vier Monate am Stück.
Das ist absolut high IQ.
Höher geht's immer.
Aber das ist schon ziemlich big brain.
Das ist nice. Subscriber.
Ich finde meine Sounds nicht, weil ich mein Fenster resized hab.
Big brain Subscriber.
KappaRot fragt.
Moin Max. Habe da mal eine Frage.
Warum fahren aktuell alle so auf VS Code ab und nicht mehr auf eine normale IDE wie Visual Studio?
Das kann man so glaube ich gar nicht sagen.
Wer auf Visual Studio Code total abfährt, sind die ganzen Frontend Jungs und Mädels.
Die finden das geil.
Weil für JavaScript plus 30 Milliarden JavaScript Frameworks, die es gibt.
Und CSS, HTML und so ist Visual Studio Code nicht schlecht.
Als 0x15 Standard Editor ist das auch ganz gut.
Aber für Sachen wie Java oder Alter.
Hab ich tatsächlich gesagt, ich glaub's nicht.
Wobei Go geht auch noch ganz gut drin.
Oder C Sharp oder so.
Da ist eine richtige IDE schon nicht verkehrt.
Da kackt auch Visual Studio relativ schnell.
Also nicht ab, aber gerät mal schnell an die Grenzen dessen, was da schon drin ist.
Ich denke mal Visual Studio könnte das auch ganz gut.
Aber die Sachen sind einfach nicht auf dem Stand, wie es bei irgendwelchen ordentlichen IDEs sind.
Das heißt eigentlich braucht man beides.
Ich hab aktuell für mein C Sharp Zeug hab ich Visual Studio und für Frontend Zeug hab ich Visual Studio Code.
Und als wir in letzter Zeit haben wir öfters auch mal Web-Anwendungen gebastelt.
Und da haben wir ja beides verwendet.
So, nutzt du Proxmox? Das läuft da so alles.
Nee, mach ich nicht.
Ich hab zwar mal einen Stream gemacht, wo ich die neue Proxmox-Version angeguckt hab, aber benutze ich nicht.
Ach ja, und die Sache, warum Leute auf Visual Studio Code zu abgehen, ist glaube ich relativ einfach zu beantworten.
Und zwar, mal kurz das GitHub-Projekt raussuchen.
Weil Projekte mit einer gewissen Verbreitung automatisch neue Leute anziehen.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass Visual Studio Code ein schlechter Editor ist oder so.
Von diesen ganzen JavaScript-Basierten ist er eigentlich der beste.
Er hat auch für Gott und die Welt irgendwelche Plugins.
Und es gibt eigentlich auch nicht mehr wirklich so eine Alternative.
Wenn man auf der Kommandozeile editieren will, würde ich ganz klar Vim nehmen, sonst nichts.
Aber da drin würde ich jetzt auch nicht irgendwelche größeren Sachen mehr basteln.
Vor einer Weile, vor so ein paar Jahren, war das voll angesagt, dass die ganzen Leute versucht haben, irgendwie in Vim aufzubohren,
auf IDE-Funktionen, aber das hat auch nicht richtig gut funktioniert.
Das geht mit Visual Studio Code und einer ordentlichen Plugins-Schnittstelle natürlich eine ganze Ecke besser.
Und große Projekte ziehen einfach immer mehr Leute an.
Also das passt und dazu ist das Ganze ganz gut.
Dazu kommt, dass die anderen Sachen halt ein bisschen schwächeln.
Was gibt es denn für ernsthafte Alternativen?
Früher, würde ich noch sagen, Emacs hatte auch sau viele Plugins.
Aber Emacs ist sowohl von der Entwicklung her als auch von den Plugins und der Plugin-Entwicklung her,
bzw. diese Extensions, diese Lisp.
Genau, ich wollte gerade sagen Link, aber Link ist ja verkehrt.
Diese Lisp-Backstage ist auch eklig zu schreiben.
Gibt es nicht wirklich viel Erfolg.
Emacs hat ein paar coole Sachen, die es so in nichts anderem gibt, wie OrgMode zum Beispiel,
aber das interessiert nicht mehr so viele Leute.
Ich muss euch übrigens gleich nochmal was richtig Cooles zeigen, was ich gefunden habe.
Ja, deswegen ist Visual Studio Code so beliebt.
Wir wollen Pfeifer, ja, mach ich, mach ich, mach ich doch an.
Der Milchmann hat abonniert.
Subscriber, vier Monate.
Huge.
Bist du nicht sogar Gründer?
Doch, du bist Gründer.
Alter, huge.
Das ist hier, da reicht schon das Prell nicht mehr für.
Das ist schon, das platzt schon.
Vierter Monat in Folge, Dankeschön.
Nice.
IQ auch nochmal erhöhen, so ist das richtig.
Blatter Dart.
Ja, ich hab letztens, ich hab letztens ein bisschen rumgebastelt mit, ähm, damit.
Da kann man jetzt experimentell Desktop-Programme erstellen mit Flutter.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich cool, aber ich glaube, das dauert noch ein bisschen, bis das spruchreif ist,
weil du hast beispielsweise kein Webview.
Was kannst du mit nem GUI-Framework anfangen heutzutage, wo kein Webview drin ist?
Jede Anwendung braucht früher oder später mal ein bisschen HTML und Browserzeug, was sie anzeigt
und sei es nur, um sich irgendwo anzumelden oder so.
Also, ein GUI-Framework, was absolut gar kein Webview unterstützt, ist schwierig zu verwenden.
Auch kann man beispielsweise keinen 3D-Content einbinden, falls man,
oder generell 3D-beschleunigten, Grafikkarten-beschleunigten Content.
Das braucht, das muss noch ein bisschen reifen, aber an sich ist echt cool.
Oh, ich wurde gehorstet, danke schön.
Huge, huge shows.
Atom, nee Atom ist eklig.
Atom gefällt mir überhaupt nicht.
Also, das letzte Mal, wo ich mich mit Atom auseinandergesetzt hab, ganz am Anfang,
ich hab den ja verwendet, wo er ganz neu war, der hier,
da konnte er keine Dateien öffnen, die größer als, oder keine Dateien speichern oder öffnen,
die größer als 1MB waren.
Ich mein, das kommt zwar relativ selten vor, aber ich mein, für einen Standard-Editor ist das nichts.
Außerdem war Atom deutlich langsamer als VS Code, wobei man halt sagen muss,
dass der Untersatz zwischen VS Code und Atom ja eigentlich der gleiche ist.
Ja, okay, Visual Studio Code für C++, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht, wie gut das ist.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich nicht so tolle.
Was für einen Mikrotik-Router hast du und nutzt du auch einen Switch von denen?
Ja, beides.
Könntest du eine Home-Lab-Tour machen?
Ja, aber erst, wenn ich aufgeräumt hab.
Also, als Switch hab ich den hier.
Ach, Quatsch.
Ich hab keinen Mikrotik-Switch.
Ich hab einen Ubiquiti-Switch, den da.
Und einen Router hab ich, den da.
Den Router, den da.
Und als Switch hab ich den da.
Das sind zwölf 10-Gigabit-Ports Glasfaser und vier 10-Gigabit-Ports Kupfer.
Weil, weil mehr Geld.
Studentens abgeben, ja, macht ja nichts.
Mit welcher Programmiersprache hast du damals angefangen?
Also, ich glaube, den allerersten Kontakt hatte ich auch wie viele mit C.
Aber, ähm, da hat mich das überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Wobei ich wieder meinen üblichen Punkt ansprechen muss, dass ich denke, dass C eine scheiß Einstiegssprache ist.
Iokun, vier Monate.
Auch hier, Gründer, vier Monats-Abo.
Der Chat-IQ steigt jetzt unermesslich, ey.
Das Tastatur-Layout ist nicht auf Englisch, das Tastatur-Layout ist auf Deutsch.
Aber die Sprache ist auf Englisch.
Und die Sprache hab ich bei allem auf Englisch.
Erstens, weil ich weiß, dass die englische Sprachausgabe besser manchmal spielen.
Aber, ähm, Software hab ich, wenn's geht, auf Englisch.
Weil, wenn es mal irgendwas gibt, was nicht funktioniert oder was ich wissen muss,
es ist viel, viel, viel einfacher, was auf Englisch zu suchen zu einem Programm und was zu finden,
als mit irgendwelchen deutschen Menüs und deutschen Fehlermeldungen da Suchmaschinen zu füttern.
Java-Programmieren.
Ja, ja, komm, da musst du jetzt einmal durch, wenn gut ist.
So, Blimetext ist auch nice.
Das hab ich früher öfters verwendet.
Wobei ich ja früher der Hardcore-WIM und EMAX-Benutzer war.
Man kann auch beides verwenden, ist überhaupt kein Problem, ja.
Standard-Text in die Topf von Windows, ja. Ist klar.
Die Fairness-Atom fühlt sich deutlich weniger responsive an als VS Code,
als ich das letzte Mal verwendet hab.
Ich hab das aber auch schon wieder zwei Jahre her.
Ja, nur mobile ist Flutter super.
Ohne den Chat grad überhaupt nicht her hinterher.
Muss euch gleich noch mal was richtig Nices zeigen an Software, was ich gefunden hab.
Hab ich vor einer Weile schon ein paar Mal ausprobiert, aber fand ich nie so gut.
Aber seit den letzten paar Versionen ist das richtig gut geworden.
Aber erst mal muss ich gucken, ob ich Chat alles jetzt gelesen hab.
Ja, und zwar, ich hab euch ja schon öfters erzählt, dass ich, wir basteln gleich weiter,
dass ich auf der Suche bin nach einem ordentlichen Notiz-Programm und To-Do-Programm
und Notification-Programm, was auf allen Plattformen funktioniert.
Und was nicht Outlook ist, irgendwas Einfaches, was sich auch ordentlich bedienen lässt,
weil Outlook lässt sich nicht ordentlich bedienen.
Zumindest To-Do's und so, wenn ich das übelste Zittellos das Fenster rumgeklicke.
Und ich habe die ganze Zeit halt gesucht, weil ich Nextcloud verwende.
Nee, nee, ich will das selbst gehostet haben.
Selbst gehostet, selbst gehostet, das ist ja das Wichtigste.
Wenn es nicht selbst gehostet werden muss, gibt es 30 Millionen Sachen.
So, und ich hab gedacht, okay, ich verwende einfach Nextcloud.
Nee, ich schwachsinn, ich verwende ja eh schon Nextcloud.
Also habe ich die ganze Zeit was gesucht, was Caldav To-Do's unterstützt.
Und Caldav Kalender und Tasks und so.
Das ist auch auf Mobile kaum ein Problem.
IOS unterstützt das alles, wobei die jetzt auch schon Probleme haben.
Und Android unterstützt das auch.
Aber es gibt uns verrecken keine gescheite Windows-Software,
die ordentlich sowohl To-Do's als auch Calendars unterstützt.
Das ist Müll und ich hab ewig gesucht und für Linux schonmal gar nicht.
Alles, alles Crap, ja.
Und dann habe ich mir gesagt, okay, ne, Taskwarrior bringt nix.
Taskwarrior bringt ja nix.
Erstens gibt es für Taskwarrior keine gescheiten Mobile-Apps.
Ich glaube eine Android-App.
Entweder die iOS-App oder die Android-App.
Eins von beiden hat gesackt.
Taskwarrior habe ich mir nämlich auch angeguckt.
Unter Windows war es glaube ich auch ein bisschen problematisch.
Und in irgendeiner Art und Weise hat auch Cross-Platform nicht gescheit funktioniert,
weil du immer zu deinem Server connecten musstest.
Deinem Taskwarrior-Server.
Das war auf jeden Fall nicht so schön.
Und dann habe ich das eine Weile versucht wie der Twin Quartz Thunderbird mit Lightning.
Das geht eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Die haben auch ganz coole Add-ons, dass man To-Do's und so relativ ordentlich machen kann.
Allerdings hat dann Thunderbird in der letzten Version absolutes Big-Brain-Play gemacht
und hat dafür gesorgt, dass alle Add-ons nicht mehr funktionieren.
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, so, wisst ihr was, ihr könnt mich jetzt mal alle am Arsch lecken.
Ich gucke jetzt mal was es sonst so gibt.
Und ich habe jetzt was gefunden.
Das nennt sich hier Joplin oder so.
Notes.
So.
Und das ist echt nice.
Das gibt es für alle Plattformen.
Das gibt es für Linux, für Windows, für Mac, für iOS, für Android.
Hat coole Funktionen und was das wichtig ist.
Also Notizprogrammen, wie man halt Notizprogrammen sich so vorstellt, ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Aber es unterstützt To-Do's.
Leider unterstützt es keine Call of To-Do's um es zu synchronisieren mit Nextcloud.
Aber das ist kein Problem.
Falls es den Client für alle Betriebssysteme gibt, kann ich einfach die eingebaute To-Do-Funktion verwenden.
Und auch über Nextcloud sinken, halt einfach über den Filesynch von Nextcloud.
Funktioniert wunderbar.
Und ich weiß jetzt auch warum mir die letzte Version nicht gefallen hat, ist, da konnten die noch keine Notifications verschicken.
Ich meine, wozu kann ich ein Fälligkeitsdatum eintragen bei irgendeinem To-Do, so nach dem Motto, hey, To-Do, keine Ahnung, hier fürs Abendessen einkaufen.
Und ich setze dann irgendwie hin, bis spätestens 16 Uhr erledigen.
Was bringt mir das, wenn ich das setzen kann, wenn das Ding keine Notifications kann.
Aber seit einem letzten Version kann das Notifications und ist richtig nice.
Also es ist wirklich cool und ich werde das jetzt versuchen.
Es gibt sogar Terminal Applications für Linux, Mac und mit WSL Windows.
Und was richtig nice ist auch, die haben sogar noch Browser Addons, wo du quasi dann Webseiten bookmarken kannst und Cross-Plattform sinken.
Und Webseiten, Screenshotten, Snapshotten, Cross-Plattform sinken und so.
Eigentlich übertrieben geil.
Und ich muss jetzt mal probieren, ich werde das jetzt mal probieren in nächster Zeit öfters zu verwenden.
Weil ich glaube, das ist das erste Programm, was ich gefunden habe, was wirklich jetzt mal alles abfackelt, was ich an To-Do und Notizen haben will.
Wozu eigentlich hardwarerad.de tun?
Ja genau, also kommen wir mal zur eigentlichen Geschichte, nachdem ich jetzt so lange rumgeschwätzt habe, um alles mögliche andere.
Und zwar braucht der Hardwarerad oder das Hardwarerad-Team, also die hier, ein Tool, wenn ich das, ich zeige euch mal das Bild.
Ich habe es euch ja letztes Mal schon gezeigt.
Er hat mir das ja versucht aufzumalen.
Wo habe ich es denn?
Hier, er hat mir versucht aufzumalen, was er braucht.
Aber das haben wir uns das letzte Mal schon angeguckt.
Aua, wie sieht die Website aus? Gar nicht, sieht doch gut aus.
Ok, das hier unten, die Schrift könnte man ein bisschen heller machen.
Aber das ist doch eine richtig ordentliche Website, die sieht nicht so überladen, Crap beladen aus, wie alles andere.
Ok, einfach simpel.
Die Schrift könnte auch ein bisschen besser Anti-Alas sein, aber ansonsten.
Naja, zumindest habe ich für die ja schon diesen Windows-Aktivierungs-Server da gebastelt.
Also nicht der, der nicht Windows aktiviert, sondern wo man Windows-Seriennummern drin verwalten kann und so ein kleines Programm,
was dann die Windows-Installation aktiviert, das ein bisschen weniger Arbeit haben.
Und da haben sie mich gefragt, ob es nicht möglich wäre, ein Programm zu basteln, das mit ihrem Sparkode-Scanner funktioniert.
Also sprich, wenn die eine Lieferung, wenn die eine Palette bekommen, mit neuen Sachen drauf,
dann wollen sie die Sachen scannen, wollen quasi dabeischreiben hier, ok, das sind jetzt 15 Seriennummern von, keine Ahnung, AMD, Ryzen 3, 3900X.
Scan, scan, scan, scan, scan. Und das Ganze speichern.
Und falls irgendwann mal Riture ist wahrscheinlich oder irgendwie, wenn mal irgendwie einer was wissen will,
dann wollen sie suchen können, quasi nach der jeweiligen Seriennummer, in welcher Bestellung das drin war, wahrscheinlich, dass es zuordnen können, von welchem Lieferant das ist oder so, keine Ahnung.
Meine erste Frage war auch, warum macht ihr das nicht mit eurer Shop- oder Warenwirtschaftssoftware?
Und ich meine, die kann das irgendwie nicht richtig. Und ich habe ihnen gesagt, ok, ich bastel irgendwas, was das macht.
Ist jetzt eigentlich nichts großartig Aufwendiges. Aber es wird kein schöneres Preis gewinnen.
So. Und das habe ich hier quei. So etwas habe ich mir auch überlegt, ob man nicht noch einen SYNC ran basteln kann für die Shop-Software.
Die meisten Barcode-Scanner tun doch eh so, als wenn sie die Tastatur eingaben. Ja, genau. So werden wir das wahrscheinlich auch machen.
So, wir werden das auch machen. Ich zeige euch mal. Also, ihr könnt euch vielleicht, also die Leute, die dabei waren im letzten Stream,
ich zeige euch mal, wie das Programm im letzten Stream ausgeschaut hat. Und dann zeige ich euch mal, wie es jetzt aussieht, weil ich habe heute nochmal ein bisschen gebastelt dran.
So, das letzte Mal, ich resette das mal. Das letzte Mal haben wir ja versucht, das Ding ein bisschen zu skinnen am Ende noch, aber das hat scheiße ausgesehen.
Das ist übrigens Windows Forms, nicht WPF und nicht OWP oder sonst was in der Richtung. Ganz oldschool Windows Forms.
Wie konnte man nochmal resetten hier in Git unter Visual Studio? Sonst musst du das über die Kommandozeile machen.
Was ich dort, wo ich deutlich mehr Übungen habe hier, reset, art, yes. Ja, okay. Warum haben wir das letzte Mal?
Form, so. Oh, der ganze Shit muss weg. So sah das Ding das letzte Mal aus. Also, jetzt sehr ultra hässlich.
Oh, der ganze Shit muss weg, so sah das Ding das letzte Mal aus, also jetzt sehr ultra
hässlich, wo ist denn die Textbox hinten oben, wo ist meine Textbox, okay keine Ahnung,
es sah das letzte Mal ultra hässlich aus, eigentlich gab es hier noch eine Textbox,
wo man suchen kann und da macht man die Bestellung auf, also es sieht wirklich, sah richtig aus
wie so eine kacke Windows 95 Anwendung, aber das Icon, Icon ist das Wichtigste, so und
ich hab mir gedacht, okay, irgendwie fand ich, sah das Ding mega hässlich aus, ich hab
mir gedacht, ey, sollen wir es nicht vielleicht doch in WPF neu machen oder sollen wir es
nicht vielleicht doch in einer Web Anwendung machen oder sollen wir nicht vielleicht doch
irgendwie gucken, ob wir es vielleicht nicht doch als UWP machen, ich hab mir gedacht,
eigentlich ist mir das alles zu viel Act für eine Anwendung, die aus zwei Fenstern besteht
und irgendwie drei Eingabefelder hat und jetzt zeige ich euch mal, wie es heute aussieht,
hier hab ich übrigens aufgeschrieben, was wir noch machen müssen, jetzt zeige ich euch
mal, wie das heute aussieht, sieht schon ein bisschen besser aus, Bäm, ist doch schon
mal Fortschritt im Vergleich zu dem anderen, oder, so, jetzt haben wir nämlich auch einen
ordentlichen, ordentlichen Listview hier, wo man das, wo man suchen kann und wo man hervorheben
kann und ich zeige euch mal, was richtig cool ist, es ist jetzt, beispielsweise, ich hab
jetzt nur eine Sache eingetragen, ja, als Test, so und ich zeige euch mal, was das jetzt,
was das für coole Sachen kann, also erstens mal natürlich, du kannst sortieren, na, das
ist jetzt natürlich schon ein riesen Vorteil im Vergleich zu dem anderen, du kannst sortieren,
das ist aber jetzt nicht auf meine Mist gewachsen, ich hab mir einfach eine GUI Library gesucht,
die ein paar bessere Controls hat, wir verwenden jetzt Sync Fusion für das Ganze, kann man
sich kaum mal kostenlos verwenden, wenn man sich mit einem Linked-in-Konto verknüpft,
da hab ich mir gedacht, ich mach mir einfach ein Fake-Linked-In-Konto und hol mir einen
Code für die Free-Version, also man kann jetzt hier sortieren, ist eigentlich ganz praktisch,
dieses Created-Add hier machen wir noch weg, das brauchen wir in der Hauptform nicht und
jetzt zeige ich euch mal, was richtig geil ist, also es sind schon ein paar richtig nice
Features drin im Vergleich zum letzten Mal, man kann suchen, beispielsweise nach AMD und
ihr seht, es wird alles ausgepl... na gut, es ist jetzt sonst nichts anderes drin, es
wird alles ausgeplendet, was nicht AMD ist und sogar AMD wird Highlighted, also wenn
ich jetzt mal hier nach R34 oder WE-Dings suche, dann sieht man, wo es gefunden wird
und alles andere wird ausgeplendet, aber oben drüber sieht man immer noch, in welcher Bestellung
das drin ist, nämlich in der Bestellung, neue Bestellung vom 19.10., was noch nicht geht
ist die Detailform aufmachen, achja, das Speichern der Daten funktioniert auch ein bisschen
anders, wie in der alten Anwendung, in der alten Anwendung haben wir so eine Embedded
NoSQL LiteDB verwendet, bis mir dann irgendwann aufgefallen ist, dass es eigentlich gar keine
so schlaue Idee gewesen, weil das Ding keinerlei Database-Migrations oder so kann, also sprich,
wenn ich mal auf die Idee kommen sollte, in Zukunft da irgendwie noch ein paar Felder
umzubenennen oder so, dann spackt das wahrscheinlich übelst rum.
Du weißt schon, dass Syncfusion über 2K, nee, kostet nicht, die Free-Version nicht,
du musst für die Free-Version nichts bezahlen und du kannst die Free-Version auch verwenden
bis, glaube ich, eine Million Euro Umsatz oder, nee, oder eine oder 100.000, 100.000 glaube
ich, ne, irgendwie so, was juckt es mich, das ist ein internes Tool, was sonst keiner
verwendet, womit ich auch nichts verdiene oder so, das kann sich jeder, kann sich jeder
herunterladen hier, ja, die haben das safe, ich aber nicht, das ist aber echt cool, das
ist das, nee, guck mal hier, Companies and Individuals less than 1Million and Viewer than
5Developers, alles, was ich, was ich habe. So, und das ist echt cool, weil da sind schon
ein paar bessere Controls dabei, das ist egal, ob Hardware Rat die Software benutzt, in dem
Fall zählt es, als zähle ich als Programmierer bzw. wie ich das eventuell irgendwie weiter
lizenziere oder so. Ich bin ja nicht Hardware Rat oder so, ich bin der Max, ich habe mit
Hardware Rat nichts zu tun, außer, dass ich für Hardware Rat was programmiere. So, und
also das ist wirklich nice, da muss man gar nicht so viel zu machen und jetzt zeige ich
euch mal was richtig, was richtig krass ist, also ein richtig nice Feature, wenn man sagt,
ok, ich will jetzt eine neue Bestellung hinzufügen, klick ich hier oben drauf, geht neues Fenster
auf neue Bestellung, nennen wir jetzt mal irgendwie Twitch, QtChat, Ayayaya, heißt die Bestellung,
so und jetzt passt mal auf. Ich kann jetzt, wenn ich hier in die Beschreibung gehe und
anfange was einzutippen oder doppelt reinklicke, kriege ich Autocompletion mit allen anderen
Beschreibungen, die es schon gibt. Das ist hier Big Brain. Gehst hier rein, fängst,
keine Ahnung, gehst hier rein, fängst an zu schreiben, äh, Risen, zack. Und das ist
richtig cool, weil ich habe mir gedacht, ähm, die Rechtschreibfehler werden auch übernommen,
ja, weil ich habe mir gedacht, die kriegen wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viele verschiedene
Teile. Benutzt du Lambda? Hä? Nee, was? Meinst du hier, äh, meint ihr so, die Geschichten,
ja klar. Ähm, ja, und das ist halt echt nice, weil ich habe mir gedacht, die bestellen
gar nicht so viel, die bestellen vielleicht, keine Ahnung, 20 verschiedene Sachen und
da musst du jedes Mal den Mist eintippen und hier machst du einfach Autovervollständigung
und sagst, okay, das ist ein AMD Risen, so. Und jetzt hast du die Möglichkeit, manuell
was einzutippen, wenn du manuell was eintippen willst, kann ja auch mal sein, dass du keinen
Scanner hast, dann kannst du hier sagen, LUL HD 2019 Omega LUL, die Seriennummer, zack,
passt. Du könntest aber auch scannen und, äh, Lambdas, Lambdas sind, im Prinzip sind
Lambdas Funktionen, ohne dass du ihnen einen Namen geben musst und dass du sie inline schreiben
kannst. Ähm, so. Und ich simuliere jetzt mal einen Scanner, da muss ich jetzt mal das
Terminal aufmachen, da sieht man das nämlich ganz gut. Ich logge nämlich mit, was in dieser
Form, äh, Form quasi getippt wird. Also erstmal, erstmal schon Keylogger ist raus, ja. Also
ich logge in dieser Form mit, was, äh, was getippt wird. Das heißt, egal wo man in dieser
Form ist, wenn der Scanner scannt, geht's immer automatisch, wird's immer automatisch
eingescannt. Und ich tu jetzt mal so, als wär ich der Scanner und es setzt jetzt voraus,
dass man den Scanner customisen kann, dass er ein Zeichen davor und ein Zeichen danach
sendet. Da müssen wir mal gucken, wenn das nicht geht, wenn das der Scanner nicht kann,
was die haben, dann mach ich halt ein Inputfeld, wo du reingehen musst, ja, das geht auch.
Ah, gut. So, ich, ich fake jetzt mal, ich fake jetzt mal Scanner. So, bla, bla, bla, bla,
blub, zack. Habt ihr gesehen? Ich war jetzt der Scanner. Bin jetzt der Scanner, ich scanne
Seriennummer und wird eingetragen. Ich hab jetzt hier, ich hab jetzt Underscore als
Startzeichen verwendet, aber da sollte man vielleicht was verwenden, was nicht in Seriennummern
davor kommt. Underscore könnte schon, könnte schon, äh, ein bisschen schwierig werden.
Der Patrick hat subscribt. Big Brain. Dude, wieder auf Stufe 3, Alter. Vier Monate auf
Stufe 3. Ich glaub's nicht, ja. Da, da brauch ich, brauch ich zwei Big Brain Emotes für,
ähm, das ist auch scheiße. Geocon hat auch abonniert. Hab ich, hab ich, hab ich ganz
übersehen, ja. Wahnsinn. Q als Signalzeichen, größer oder kleiner Zeichen. Hey, das finde
ich eigentlich cool. Das eine Zeichen zum Starten, das andere Zeichen zum, ähm, Sargent
Flakes Twitch Prime, dankeschön. Ja, so, so schaut das Ganze jetzt aus. Das ist, finde
ich, schon viel schöner benutzbar als der andere Kram, den ich da gebastelt hab. Gefällt
mir. Hat was. Und am besten, am besten finde ich eigentlich die Autovervollständigung.
Ähm, und, irgendjemand hat gefragt, wie ich das Ganze speichere, das zeige ich euch jetzt
gleich. Mit größer Zeichen am Anfang und kleiner Zeichen am Ende ist es bei uns umgesetzt
worden. Ach, du hast, ach, du hast es auch so mit Eingaben vom Scanner gemacht. Nein,
ich, ja, wahrscheinlich mach ich das auch so mit größer und kleiner Zeichen. Da bin
ich nicht der Einzige, der auf diese, auf die blöde Idee gekommen ist. Ähm, ja, ähm,
was man, was man noch machen kann, ist natürlich, man kann, man kann Sachen löschen. Das ist
natürlich nicht verkehrt. Oh, ich, ich tu jetzt noch mal so, als bin ich Scanner und
scanne ein bisschen. So. Ähm, so, und das ist jetzt kein AMD Ryzen, sondern das ist
jetzt ein Intel, wie heißen die aktuellen CPUs? 9, 9, 0, 0k oder so. Gibt's, gibt's
den? Oder wir machen was anderes. China-Netzteil ist das jetzt. China-Netzteil. So, jetzt drücken
wir das Save. Was noch nicht geht, ist, dass er automatisch Refreshed. Muss ich auch noch
als To Do reinschreiben. Das müssen wir auch noch machen. Auto, Refresh, Main Form. So,
und wenn man das jetzt speichert, zack, dann reloadet er noch nicht, weil's, äh, weil's
noch nicht implementiert ist, dass er reloadet. So, wenn ich jetzt wieder neu starte, dann,
dann andere Kram auch alles drin. So, was ist denn? Jetzt haben wir zwei Bestellungen
drinne. Einmal neue Bestellungen, einmal neue Bestellungen. Achso, ich hab die Dinger einfach
nur neue Bestellungen genannt. Das ist natürlich taktisch nicht so geschickt. Ich hätte die
ein bisschen besser benennen sollen. Anstatt neue Bestellungen. Wobei, ich hab die Bestellungen
doch Q-Chat Ayayaya genannt. Das, das scheint doch rumzubuggen. Eigentlich sollte da jetzt
Q-Chat Ayayaya drinstehen in der Bestellung. Tja, da müssen wir mal gucken, warum das nicht
funktioniert. Das gucken wir als erstes. Bestellungs. So, ähm, bugged irgendwie ein bisschen kann
das sein. Warum steht denn in der Description drinne? Tja, gut. Das scheint irgendwie nicht
so ganz zu funktionieren, würd ich sagen. Aber, wär auch viel zu einfach, wenn der
Kram immer auf alle Hüfte funktionieren würde. Okay, müssen wir mal gucken an der Stelle,
wo das gespeichert wird. Wahrscheinlich ist das relativ simpel. Ähm, die ganze wird hier
unten irgendwo gespeichert. Also sprich, wenn man hier unten auf save drückt. Ah, kann
das sein, dass das einfach, dass das nie geupdatet wird? Die Granatierung ist wahnsinnig big
ein. Warum wird das nicht geupdatet? Hier wird der Kram doch eigentlich alles angelegt.
Achso, und übrigens toll, dass die Dinger Textbox 2 heißen. Vielleicht sollte ich die
Dinger mal ordentlich benennen. Und zwar, das ist nicht Textbox 2, sondern das ist die
Textbox für, ähm, das wird, das wird nicht richtig gespeichert, denk ich mir. Ähm,
das ist nicht, das ist nämlich nicht die Textbox 2, das ist die, die, keine Ahnung, Description
Box oder so. Wieder. Hat der Name hier jetzt auch angepasst? Ja, sehr schön. Dann blickt
man nämlich auch mal ein bisschen durch. Das ist ein bisschen mit heißer, heißer Nadel
geschrickt, ne. Aber hier, hier, hier legt er das doch eigentlich an. Also sprich, wenn
ich's hinzufüge, wenn ich's hinzufüge, dann nimmt er das aus der Description, setzt
die Seriennummer und edit das. Ok, also dann gucken wir mal mit dem SQLite Browser mal
was Verrückliches, was der Flo vorgeschlagen hat, warum das Ganze nicht funktioniert. Desktop,
äh, wie heißt das Ding hier? Web Application, ne WinForms App 11, besser Name. Oh, das gucken
wir mal rein. Ne, das wurde nicht richtig gespeichert. Die Seriennummer wurden aber
richtig gespeichert, was mich zu der Annahme führt, dass die Textbox irgendwie rumschwackt.
Lässt mich vermuten, dass die Textbox irgendwie rumschwackt. Ok, probier mal das noch mal
aus. Also wenn ich was Neues hinzufüge, hier, neue, neu. Achso, ah, ich glaub ich weiß
wo ganz leh, guck mal. Also das erste, warum es nicht funktioniert, schon mal das hier.
Von der Order setze ich nie die Description. Und das Ding nennen wir jetzt mal anders um,
äh, irgendwie so, dass ich mir das merken kann. Ok, das sollte das jetzt eine schon mal fixen.
Gucken wir mal, bla bla bla bla, bla bla bla. So, ich tu mal wieder so, als wäre ich Scanner,
jetzt tue ich das hinzu. Ähm, wobei das ist doof, wir machen das mal anders. Ähm, ich
wusste ja irgendwie hier, keine Ahnung, blub. Ok, save. Ok, jetzt gucken wir mal was passiert.
Hä? Das scheint irgendwas mit der Textbox nicht richtig zu sein. Weil jetzt hat das
funktioniert. Ach ne, Moment. Aber die Order stimmt auch nicht. Ah, also. Moment, also
an der Stelle auch vollkommen falsch, wo ich das setze. Muss das hier unten beim Speichern
setzen. Sonst mach ich das ja alles doppelt und dreifach. Ok, probieren wir das Ganze
nochmal aus. Egal, save. Hä? Moment, kann das sein, dass ich irgendwie meine Textboxen
vertauscht hab oder so? Hab ich irgendwo meine Textboxen vertauscht? Das ist doch vollkommen
falsch. Hier müsste eigentlich drinstehen eins, zwei, drei. What? Ich muss noch, ich
muss noch rtx on machen. Ja, genau. Ok, gucken wir nochmal. Was ist beim hinzufüllen? Description?
Das ist aber echt merkwürdig. Nehm ein Datacrit. Das ist ein Datacrit. Das ist aber
merkwürdig. Ok, also nochmal ganz langsam gucken. Was mach ich denn hier beim Speichern
unten? Updated ads setz ich bloß. Ok, das ist ok. Das brauch ich an der Stelle garantiert
nicht mehr. Ok, wisst ihr was? Wir gucken jetzt tatsächlich noch mit dem SQLite Explorer
und gucken, ob die Anzeige nicht jetzt verkehrt ist. Hä? Da gebastelt. Sehr merkwürdig.
Ok, das Ding heißt QtChat. Beschreibung, da ist jetzt drinne keine Ahnung, 0w und jetzt
machen wir hier irgendwelche Seriennummer rein. So. Hier. Ne, ne, das liegt nicht auf dem
Netzwerk. Das ist aber echt merkwürdig. So, gucken wir mal jetzt, was drinne steht.
Das ist jetzt ok. Ok, dann hab ich irgendwelche Probleme, wenn ich die Felder zwischenzeitlich
update. Da muss ich mal gucken, warum der rumspackt. Aber wir machen erst mal die anderen
Punkte. Aber prinzipiell ist das an der richtigen Stelle kommt das an. Das ist Seriennummer,
das ist Description. Dernummer, das passt. Ok, das passt prinzipiell schon. Der update
das zwischenrinnig. Da muss ich mal gucken, was der für Schmerzen hat. Äh, was ist SQL
dafür geeint, damit z.B. mehrere Personen darauf zugreifen, wenn die DB auf einem Netzlaufwerk
liegt oder sollte man der für, eher für MySQL liegen. Also, also, äh, SQLite auf dem
Netzlaufwerk würde ich nicht unbedingt, ähm, würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt. Da könnt's
auch Probleme geben, irgendwas zu locken oder so. Generell würde ich mir überlegen, wenn
ich SQLite verwende und das mit mehreren Benutzern verwende, da muss man das, also
das geht, das ganze prinzipiell schon machen. Aber ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, wie das
im größeren Ziel aussieht. Ich hab da keine großen Erfahrungen mit SQLite. Ähm, mein,
theoretisch geht das, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich machen würde. Naja, aber zumindest
ist das komisch. Irgendwie, irgendwie packt das an manchen Stellen rum. So, das erste,
das nächste, was ich machen muss, ich muss aus meiner Haupt, muss ich ein bisschen schöner
machen, ähm, dieses Create braucht hier drin kein Mensch. Das schmeiße ich jetzt gerade
mal an der Stelle wieder raus. Das sieht doch ein bisschen übersichtlicher aus. So, was
man natürlich noch machen muss, ist, wenn man den Kram anklickt, dass er dann die Detailansicht
aufmacht mit den ganzen Werten drin. Hahaha, neues Testament, ey, das ist, der Witz ist
wirklich gut. Ich hab's erst nicht gecheckt, ja, aber jetzt, wenn ich das ganze nur mal
durchlese, ist das eigentlich echt lustig. Wenn die die B auf ein Rätsel aufklickt,
ist das mal Verspätung. Ja, das ist richtig. Das muss man erst, ja, das dauert, das dauert
eine Weile. So, ich bin ganz froh, dass ich diese komische optische, die optisch bisschen
hübschenen Controls für Windows Forms noch gefunden habe, weil, ähm, das alte sah
wirklich Crap-mäßig aus, ja. Aber das ist jetzt eigentlich ganz nett. So, ähm, also
was wird man als nächstes machen? Bestellt sich jetzt nicht über Umlangung, das haben
wir uns angeguckt, dass es irgendeine Geschichte von zwischendrin Sachen nicht aktualisiert
wird. Da muss ich mal in Ruhe gucken. Äh, Terok, Switch Prime, Dankeschön, Big Brain.
Ähm, Create Date aus Mainform raus, haben wir gemacht. Drag and Drop mach ich jetzt
nicht, da muss ich erst mal angucken, wie das geht. Ähm, ja, das was am meisten gescannt
wurde, wollte ich hier als Default reinschreiben, bzw. als ersten Vorschlag in der Autocompletion
anbieten. Das glaube ich nicht verkehrt, wenn wir das sortieren, nachdem wie oft was
vorgekommen ist. Ähm, dann müssen wir als nächstes das da machen, dass die Mainform
neu geladen wird, irgendwie, wenn neue Daten hinzugefügt werden, alles andere ist beknackt,
ja. Also sprich, wir müssen das einmal neu einlesen, weil sonst ist es total bescheuert.
Ähm, Sound aus. Die Gruppen werden nicht richtig sortiert, ok. Also ich glaube das
ist das erste was wir machen. Das muss ich mir hier unten drunter mal hinschreiben,
ähm, dass ich mir das mal angucke, warum das so komisch rumspackt. Wahrscheinlich relativ
simple, weil ich an irgendeiner Stelle, wo es im UI aktualisiert, unten drunter nicht
aktualisiert wird. Äh, Ruffy Monkey, was genau möchtest du mir mitteilen? Dass du
eine krasse Datenbank Pro bist, oder was? Ich weiß auch, dass man das anders machen
kann. Vio, Vio still abonniert Stufe 1, Dankeschön. Pog. So, dann würde ich sagen, machen wir
das jetzt mal. Achja stimmt, das müssen wir zuerst machen, das packt nämlich auch noch
rum. Ich bin nämlich ziemlich, äh, ziemlich beknackt hier an der Stelle unten, hab ich,
ähm, gemacht. Ich sehr, ich edit die Sache immer. Wo das Problem ist, ich kann das nicht
immer adden, ich muss das updaten. Also sprich, wenn das eine neue, wenn das ein neuer Eintrag
ist, dann machen wir ein add. Wenn das kein neuer Eintrag ist, dann machen wir ein update.
Ansonsten packt das rum. So, ich überleg grad, wie man das mit dem, mit dem updaten von
der Mainform gescheit machen können. Also ich will ja, dass wenn ich was neues hinzufüge,
ich blablabla, wenn ich was neues hinzufüge, will ich ja beim speichern, dass die Mainform
neu geladen wird. Das könnt man entweder machen, wenn man die Form zu macht, aber das
ist eigentlich doof. Wir bräuchten irgendeinen Event, wir müssten irgendwie Bescheid sagen
so nach dem Motto, ich hab save geklickt und wenn ich save geklickt hab, dann muss ich
updaten. Wie macht man das am besten? Wir könnten, wir könnten hier drin ein Event machen,
wir könnten hier drin ein Event machen, so nach dem Motto saved und wenn wir hier unten
speichern, dann werfen wir das saved Event. Ne modaldingsdialog will ich net machen. Also
wir könnten, wir könnten, wir könnten irgendwie sowas hier machen. Saved oder so. Hallo, nein,
das gibt es öfters. Ach Mist, den Kram gibt es öfters. Saved. Dann reichen wir das durch.
Gibt es für SQLer, ich hab keine Objekte, doch, doch, doch. Ich hab ja auch mal eher
F-Core reingeschmissen, weil ich keinen Bock hatte irgendwelche SQL Statements zu schreiben.
So und jetzt schmeißen wir ein Event beim speichern. Müsste doch eigentlich funktionieren.
Saved. So und jetzt können wir bei uns in der Mainform. Event row change, du lässt
Automat speichern, aber du brauchst keinen Saved Button. Das ist cool. Das ist tatsächlich
ganz praktisch. Du meinst bei dem Ding hier. Gucken was da alles changed ist. Heißt wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich heißt das nur beim offiziellen Microsoft Control und hier heißt das wahrscheinlich
irgendwie anders, aber das gibt es garantiert hier auch. Und der View. Ich hab gar kein
richtiges Data Table. Ich hab einfach nur ein Array aus Objekts, was aus EF Core rauskommt
dafür. Aber ist ja auch, das bei dem Update passt eigentlich so denke ich mal ganz gut.
So, wir gehen jetzt mal zurück in die Mainform und gucken, wenn das Ganze zugemacht wird.
Was tut es? Ich hab eigentlich die Punktfragezeichen. Was ist, wenn das Ding null ist, also wenn,
ach was mach ich da eigentlich für ein Schwarzinsert? Also sprich, wenn hier nichts dran attached
ist, dann invoked, also dann ruft das nicht die Methode auf. Also wenn das hier im Endeffekt,
wenn das hier null ist, dann macht er das hier nicht. Das Ding hat auch irgendwie einen
absolut Zungenbrechernamen, das Ding. Null, boah, wie heißt das Ding? Irgendwie Null Blah
Questionmark Operator. Das Ding hat ganz abartige Namen. Das ist so ähnlich wie True Doppelpunkt,
die Fragezeichen. Ja, bloß dass du nicht alles doppelt und dreifach schreiben musst.
Null, wie heißt dieser Kram nochmal? Save, was, call the save? Navigation Operator. Heißt
aber offiziell nie so, oder? Ist das so? Save, null, null, Null Conditional Operator heißt
das, genau. Das Ding, genau. Und man kann das jetzt auch, oder geht es vielleicht schon
immer, man kann das auch als Index für BIOS verwenden. Ich meine, man kann es auch übertreiben,
ja. Aber für Events ist das wirklich ganz praktisch. So, okay, gehen wir mal in die
Einform gucken. Wir gucken, das müssen wir auf jeden Fall noch an eine Stelle zusammenfassen,
deswegen habe ich es ja auch noch in die Tudu reingeschrieben. Ich habe das heute in zwei
Stunden, indem ich hier mit meinem Zeug fertig war, zusammen gewurstet, dass es funktioniert
und besser ausschaut als das letzte und dass das auch mal fertig wird irgendwann. Also
ich habe es, ich glaube nicht, dass wir heute komplett fertig werden. Okay, also wir gucken
jetzt mal, wie kann man das jetzt am besten, also sprich, wenn die Form closed, nee nicht
closed, wenn die, ach Quatsch, weg machen. Also sprich, wenn jetzt einer den Save Button
drückt, dann, was machen wir dann? Dann laden wir den Kram neu, würde ich sagen. Da müssen
wir mal gucken, dass wir vorher richtig gespeichert haben, jawoll, haben wir, passt. So, wo habe
ich nie das Laden aus der Datenbank da oben. Man merkt halt schon, dass es ein bisschen
mit Halsanatel gestrickt ist, aber das brauchen wir an der Stelle garantiert nicht. Also laden
wir den Kram neu, wenn man auf save drückt. Und dann müssen wir noch sagen refresh. Und
das müssen wir invogen, weil wenn wir das nicht invogen, dann fresh uns das ganze Ding,
das wird sonst nichts. Weil das, wobei, nee, müssten wir nicht invogen, das kommt beides
aus dem GUI-Smart, das eigentlich kein Ding. Müsste eigentlich funktionieren, wobei, geht
das von, ja, das muss von einer Form in die andere Form, müsste das auch funktionieren.
Okay, also wenn jetzt einer den save Button drückt, dann müsste das eigentlich weichern
und neu laden. Gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert. Okay, also mal ein neues Fenster auf. Blablabla,
blablabla. Okay, und jetzt save. Oh, what the fuck. Alter, was jetzt? Smokersmoke. Was
genau möchte ich mir denn diese Fehlermeldung jetzt sagen? At least one option. What? Okay,
okay. What? Eh? Was ist doch da oben genauso? Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Eh? Muss ich jetzt vorher clearen oder so? MrAmec, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön. Das funktioniert
hier oben doch auch. Warum sollte das da unten nicht mal funktionieren? Muss man das, das
muss man bestimmt, das muss man bestimmt vorher clearen oder irgendwie sowas. Warte mal, warte
mal, wir probieren mal was aus. Und zwar, ich mach jetzt erst mal, erst mal mal das
mal hier. Das ist jetzt merkwürdig. Blablabla. Aha. Der spackt beim Refresh rum.
Warum spackt der denn beim Refresh rum? Das leuchtet mir jetzt nicht wirklich ein. Ich
werd' mal kurz meine Datepunk wegschmeißen, dass es ein bisschen leerer wird. Spackt der
beim Refresh rum? Muss ich das doch invoken? Aber ist doch eigentlich, GUI-Thread ist GUI-Thread,
das sollte doch eigentlich keine Probleme machen. Wär' ich jetzt nicht mitgerechnet, dass der
an der Stelle irgendwie rumspackt? Ja. Führen wir mal aus. Add. Neue Bestellung. Blabla. Save.
Gut, das Refresh nicht. Hä? Jetzt kackt es gar nicht mehr ab. Aber Refreshen tut es auch
nicht mehr. Wo ist denn das Problem? Wie verwenden wir den Kram überhaupt richtig?
Was, weil er nicht sortieren muss?
Genau. Filter?
Ne, ich mach' hier, ich schreib' hier eine, äh, ich schreib' hier eine komplett neue
Sache. Ah, okay. Äh, also was hat der, was hat der damit für Schmerzen, das weh ich
nicht. Genau das Gleiche, wenn ich oben doch auch. Genau das Gleiche mach' ich hier doch
auch. Also exakt, exakt das Gleiche. Warum spackt es da oben rum, äh, da oben nicht rum
und hier spackt das rum. Ah, die muss ich nicht verstehen. Ähm, ich mach' mal kurz den
Kram aus. Steht alles schön untereinander, okay. Darf man diese Sache vielleicht nur
einmal neu, nee, oder? Man darf hier sicherlich nicht nur einmal neu. Ha! Das hat irgendwas
mit den Gruppen zu tun. Das hat irgendwas mit den Gruppen-Settings zu tun. What? Okay.
Funktioniert. Gut, das Löschen wird noch nicht funktionieren, oder? Ähm, das Löschen
kommt ja auch nie, kommt ja auch nie in der Collection an, aber what? Was hat es denn,
was hat das denn mit den Gruppen zu tun? Okay, das ist wahrscheinlich irgendeine framework-spezifische
Sache jetzt. Was jucken denn denn die Gruppen davon? Okay. Was auch immer. Kein Schimmer.
Aber an sich funktioniert das Updaten. Das verstehe ich nicht. Ah, ich mal guck, dass
das normale Updaten tut. Ja, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla. Also ich muss den Kram unbedingt
mal ein bisschen, äh, ordentlicher zusammenschreiben, weil ich hab' jetzt zwei Mal, zwei Methoden
hier aufgerufen, wenn einmal hier mit Enter drücken und einmal hier für Plus drücken
und so, bla, bum, bum. Ähm, da hier, Q-Chat, Beschreibung, Aja, Ja, Zufügen, Serie-Nummer,
irgendwas, save, zack, funktioniert direkt. Was hat der, warum spackt das auf einmal? Und
warum geht das mit dem Sortieren nicht nachdem man das geändert hat? Das liegt eindeutig
da dran, wenn man das hier updatet, dann spackt der rum. Wenn ich das hier nicht mache, also
wenn ich das hier einfach nur öffne und sortier, ach nee, ok. Äh, Wonka Smoke, Alter. Warum?
Wo ist das Problem? Ah, ich glaub' ich weiß, ich glaub' ich weiß woran das liegt. Ich
weiß woran das liegt, glaub' ich. Ah, ich glaub' ich weiß woran das liegt. Ich dachte,
ich könnte, ich könnte mich da vordrücken. Ähm, ich dachte, ich könnte mich da vordrücken,
dass die Anzeige hier hässlich ist, indem ich hier, ich zeig' euch das mal kurz, ähm,
ah, wird's wahrscheinlich liegen, ne, ähm, Order. Dass es hier richtig angezeigt wird,
hab' ich hier Two-String überschrieben, weil sonst steht ja nur drin, dass es ein Order,
sonst war es irgendwie, und wahrscheinlich stört ihn das irgendwie, weil wenn ich das
hier sortiere ist kein Problem, aber das hier kann man nicht sortieren einfach so. Ok,
das ist interessant, das war mir so nicht klar. Und, liegt das vielleicht doch mit den, mit
den, mit den Data, vielleicht doch da dran? Also beim einfügen liegt das bestimmt auch
da dran. Ja. Ok, ich hab' ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung warum man das machen muss. Mehr
Einträge mit, was soll das Tool später machen? Ähm, dass, du kannst Seriennummer von Produkten
suchen, in welcher Bestellung die vorgekommen sind. So. Also ist nicht für mich, ähm, muss
ich jetzt da irgendwie, ok Moment Leute, ich muss jetzt nochmal was ausbrechen, ich mach'
das hier nochmal weg, dann sieht die Anzeige zwar hässlich aus, wie, wie kommt's zum Einsatz
von, ähm, oh wie heißt das Ding hier, SF-Dings hier, Sync Fusion? Einfach weil die eine kostenlose
Lizenz haben. Einfach weil die eine kostenlose Lizenz haben. Alles. Weil die eine kostenlose
Lizenz haben und ganz gut ausschauen und ich die Kram nicht neu in WPF oder UWP machen
muss. Ok, das juckt die nicht. Muss ich da jetzt wirklich? Eye Comparable irgendwie im,
aber warum? Ja gut, muss ich, das ist ja ein eigener Typ. Rings, haben das? Ok, ja machen
wir mal, machen wir, ähm, machen wir. Eye Comparable, was macht man da mittlerweile
hier, den, den, den da? Ah, Compare to. Für was ist Compare? Compare ist die Geschichte
mit größer, kleiner, gleich, oder? Also minus eins, null und eins, ne, irgendwie so ist das.
Die Spalte sollten in Ordnung, ach, ah, du, also heißt das, was meinst du jetzt für
die Geschichte mit den Gruppen oder meinst du für, ähm, Vira generell das handelt,
was da drinne steht? Also ok, aber so müsste das eigentlich, eigentlich, ok, ähm, also
im Prinzip, kann ich da jetzt einfach sagen, es ist ja eigentlich egal, alles gleich. So
und zumindest jetzt müsste es nicht mehr abkatzen. Das Sortieren kann man custom handeln. Ok,
das, das, das ist gut zu, ja das Sortieren, also das Filtern habe ich custom gemacht, das
Sortieren wusste ich nicht, dass das funktioniert. Ich habe das ja auch noch nie vorher benutzt.
Zumindest, der eigentliche Grund warum ich das benutze ist, weil sie eine Free-Lizenz
haben und weil es ganz gut aussieht, im Vergleich zu Oldschool Windows Forms. Aber guck mal,
wie schön die Autovervollstellung funktioniert. So, mal gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Hat das jetzt hinzugefügt? Also mit den Gruppen spackt übelst rum, das checke ich nicht.
Hast du eine Ahnung, äh, Krasios, wenn du das schon mal benutzt hast, ähm, warum es
ihn stört, bzw. warum er nicht refresht, wenn ich Gruppen drin habe? Wenn ich die Gruppen
rausnehme, refresht er sofort, das juckt ihn überhaupt nicht. Wenn ich die Gruppen rausnehme,
dann etwas hinzufüge, hier blablabla, zack, ist da. Aber wenn ich Gruppen drin habe, spackt
er rum, ich habe keine Ahnung warum. Sollen wir mal gucken. Die Gruppen machen sie mal aus,
ja. Hätte ich auch machen sollen. Wow, jetzt hat es funktioniert. Ach, nice, jetzt funktioniert
es. Diese iComparable-Geschichte war es echt komisch. So, dann sag mal hier unten jetzt
noch, keine Ahnung, auto-expand-groups, aber das habe ich eben doch schon gesagt. Dann
sag ich es eben noch mal, gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert. Oh, add, ich musste jetzt echt
mal was anfassen, klein, blablabla. Es lagged übrigens die Autovervollstellung, weil
ich ja so viel Zeug drin habe, also ich musste schon mal ein bisschen begrenzen. Warum öffnet
er die jetzt nicht? Kein Bock. Kann ich so expand, expand, all-group machen wir jetzt.
Okay, er sollte es zwar automatisch machen, aber macht er anscheinend nicht. Wieso machst
du das nicht einfach über den Debugger? Was soll ich dir sagen? Konsolendebugging ist
das einzig wahre. So, blablabla, nice. Jetzt geht, jetzt funktioniert es. Okay, man muss
den Kram danach noch mal explizit sagen, er soll den Kram wieder aufmachen. Okay, ja,
muss man wissen, muss man wissen. Okay, wir machen jetzt mal eine eigene, links, hier,
Open, keine Ahnung, ja, Order Form, klar. Also wir müssen das nur an einer Stelle alles
aufmachen. So, und das da unten machen wir ab, fort, setzen es da durch, weil da kann
man jetzt auch den anderen Knopf drücken, zack, hinzufügen, select, autocomplete, select,
laggen wird nicht toleriert, naja, ja, guck da ist es jetzt hier, da wird es hinzufügen,
also das funktioniert. Gut, das löschen geht glaube ich noch nicht, fuck, bam, in your
face. Das löschen funktioniert nicht, weil, wobei, muss ich mal gucken, das löschen das
war jetzt was anderes. Warum programmierst du mit einer nicht über Linux, weil das eine
Windows Desktop Anwendung ist. Eine Windows Desktop Anwendung ist schwierig über Linux
zu gebasteln. Oh, neue Bestellung, zack, entfernen, okay, geht nicht, da weiß ich aber bereits
liegt, dass das nicht geht. Wieso programmierst du mit einer Sampler? Könntest du das auch
in C machen oder in Go machen oder in JavaScript machen oder in, pass mal auf, in Erlang oder
in Lisp oder in Kobol oder eventuell auch in Java. Aber wir wollen es ja mal nicht so
sehr übertreiben jetzt hier, ne. Okay, das Updaten funktioniert. So, das löschen klappt
nicht, weil, ich weiß warum das löschen nicht klappt, wenn wir nämlich hier draufklicken,
das ist einfach Delete Selected Records, das, ähm, deletet die Sachen gar nicht. Swift,
ja, Swift ist nice, also ich hab ganz, ganz wenig, ich hab also wirklich, eigentlich programmiert,
was dann auch Info auf MyOS gerät gelaufen, jetzt hab ich noch nichts in Swift, aber ich
hab mir mal ein bisschen Swift Tutorials und, ähm, ich guck mir ab und zu halt auch so die
aktuellen, von irgendwelchen Konferenzen und so die ganzen Webcasts an. Und ich muss sagen,
Swift gefällt mir echt gut. Was mir in der ersten oder in der ersten Swift Version ein
bisschen, bisschen schwer gefallen ist, durchzusteigen, ist, wie das ganze String Handling funktioniert
mit den unterschiedlichen Encodings. Das war ein bisschen, ähm, da hatten aber mehrere
Leute das Problem und ich glaub, das ist aber, das haben sie jetzt, äh, schöner gemacht.
Also, okay, wir müssen jetzt erstmal gucken, wie wir hier rauskriegen, was davon Selected
ist. Data Grid, Selected, Selected, Selected Item, wir haben nur ein Item Selected, mehr
geht nicht, Selected Item, äh, ich, ich, wir machen jetzt mal eine, wobei, weil die Leute
hier so auf dem Debugger stehen, aber das halt mal mit dem Debugger, ja. So, wenn ich
jetzt hier auf löschen klicke, müsste er da anhalten. Löschen, zack. Okay, was steht
da drinnen? Order, blablub, sehr schön, steht das Richtige drin. Das heißt, wir können
jetzt hergehen und sagen, ähm, Selected Item wollen wir löschen. Items, remove. Müssen
wir das casten dafür? Wahrscheinlich müssen wir das casten. So, und jetzt sollte das mit
dem löschen eigentlich auch funktionieren. Was genau brauchst du da? Wir bauen für Hardware
gerade ein Tool, wo er mit einem, mit einem Scanner, ähm, neue Seriennummer scannen kann.
Funktion, die Funktionsstar sind die besten, ne? Wo er mit einem Scanner neue, neue Lieferungen
scannen kann und dann irgendwie in einem halben Jahr gucken kann, welche Seriennummer in welcher
Lieferung drin war. Also eigentlich soll irgendwie so ein bisschen Tutorial, Tutorial Zeug. Ist
es das gleiche wie casten? Nee, ist es nicht. Casten, also der cast in Klammern, wenn das
sich nicht konvertieren lässt, geht direkt kaputt. Ähm, beziehungsweise der, der castet
einfach auf, ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste. Mit S kommt Null zurück, aber er kackt nicht
ab, wenn ich das irgendwie. Wobei ich mir jetzt gar nicht sicher bin, es gibt ja verschiedene
Varianten. Äh, Difference, die Scharp zwischen S ist und cast. Wieso machst du das nicht
in Python? Warum machst du das nicht in Ruby? Warum machst du das nicht in Go? Warum machst
du das nicht in JavaScript? Ähm, ja, Python ist nicht unbedingt jetzt das, was ich für
Winner aus Desktop Software verwenden würde. Ach genau, ist castet nicht, ist guckt nur,
ist guckt nur und gibt True oder False zurück, ob das Objekt sich cast, nee, nee, ob das Objekt
dieser spezielle Typ ist. S gibt Null zurück, wenn es sich nicht konvertieren lässt und
der Casting Operator, also das in Klammern, das richtig casten, dann kackt es direkt ab.
Keylogger, Keylogger ist schon integriert. Ok, mal gucken, ob das mit dem Löschen funktioniert.
Ok, adden, bla bla blub, add add add, mal gucken, was hinzu kommt, save, tak, Räumestellung
delete, delete, what? What the hell? Warum geht das Löschen nicht? Wonka, Smoke, ich
hab das Löschen kaputt gemacht. Lebt der Versand-Tracksor noch? Äh, ja, ich hab aber
nicht weiter gemacht. Wo ist das Problem? Hier, hier, das mag er irgendwie nicht. Warum
mag er das nicht? Was hat er für Schmerzen jetzt? Was mag er da dran nicht? Ja, da, add
add add, löschen, add add add, löschen, save, löschen, löschen, ok, also prinzipiell
funktioniert das noch. Was mag er hier dran jetzt nicht? Liegt da den Funktionsnamen eindeutig,
eindeutig muss. Außerdem Leute, das sind die absolute next level big brain Funktionsnamen.
Was ist das für Zeichenspart? Hä, the fuck? Ich bin verwirrt. Wir haben doch sogar eben
nachgeguckt, dass das funktioniert. Ich bin echt verwirrt. Warum geht das Löschen nicht?
What? Hä? Das muss funktionen, wir haben extra gerade reingeguckt, ob da das Item drin ist,
aber der macht ja, es ist ja nicht so, also der macht einfach gar nichts oder hab ich
nicht das Richtige selectet. Doch, hä? What? Das Programmier ist so ein Tool, wo man Seriennummern
suchen kann, in welcher Bestellung die Seriennummer drin waren. Also eigentlich was kleines. Allerdings
mit einem UI Framework, was ich im Leben noch nicht verwendet hab. Debugging die Remove Funktion.
Hä? Das check ich jetzt grad nicht. Aber wenn der Cast nicht klappt, dann sollte er zumindest
Delete Active Item sehen. Guckt hier. Selected Item.
Hä? Selected Item ist das hier. Wartet mal.
Nein. Wartet mal. Ob ich weiß woran das liegt. Das funktioniert. Das funktioniert. Hast du
zur Zeit eine Freundin? Ja, in den Twitch Chat. Das funktioniert. Ich glaube wir müssen
einfach nur Refreshen. Ich glaube das funktioniert alles. Ich glaube das funktioniert eigentlich
alles. Passt mal auf, ich glaube ich weiß woran das liegt. Ha! Oh. Geht nur einmal. Ne.
Es ist ein bisschen kaputt. Oh, da ist ein Fehler im Icon. Ganz schlimm. Neue Bestellung,
da ist kein Lull drin. Man muss jetzt neu anklicken. Aber ich glaube ich weiß woran
das liegt. Wenn ich das jetzt mal hinzufüge. So, löschen wir mal irgendwas. Man aktualisiert
es hier an der Stelle nicht, aber ich weiß woran das gelegen hat. Ich glaube das liegt
da dran, dass wenn ich es hier lösche, aus dieser Collection mit Items, ich es hier nicht
mal löschen kann, weil quasi die Sache unten drunter schon weg ist. Weil der hier greift
da drauf zu. Deswegen versucht das zu löschen und finde das nicht mehr. Also vielleicht
geht das, vielleicht geht das wenn ich so rum mache. Machen wir noch mal einen Breakpoint
und gucken nach. Machen wir es mal so rum, vielleicht geht das. Oh. Continue. Ja, es
ist weg oder? Ich glaube es ist weg. Ne, ist nicht weg. War es weg oder war es nicht
weg? Das erste. War das erste weg oder nicht weg? War noch vorher eins mehr. Ja doch. Der
wählt bloß nicht das gleiche wieder aus was vorher selectet war. Na ja gut. Das ist auf
jeden Fall nicht schön synchronisiert. Ich glaube das müssen wir doch mit irgendeiner
Data Table machen oder so. Dann muss man den Kram nicht von Hand machen. Na ja, aber
finde ich schon mal ganz gut. Was ich also nicht ganz verstehe ist, wenn ich jetzt den
Kram hier hinzufüge. Ja guck das ist nicht gesynkt, das ist nicht gesynkt, das sackt.
Das muss ich anders machen. Das ist Müll. Der löscht das hier, danach löscht das da.
Kann man vielleicht, kann man es vielleicht einfach so machen, dass ich sag hier remove,
lasse das weg und refresh dann einfach nur. Das funktioniert. Aber was jetzt noch nicht
geht ist das save und lösche den Kram dann. Das speichert er dann nicht, das kommt nicht
gelöscht an. Das ist mir jetzt noch nicht ganz klar. Da gucken wir mal, ob ich hier
irgendwelche Subs übersehen hab. Das ist der Amec. Weiß ja nicht, ob ich das vorgelegt
haben habe, aber Dankeschön für den Sub. Terox und xFatal. Vier Monate in der Folge.
Huge Sub. Poggers Massive Sub. Das ist Visual Studio. Kostet mittlerweile auch nichts mehr.
Was ich jetzt nicht so ganz kapiere ist, why, wenn ich das update, dass dann nicht gelöscht
wird. Das ist jetzt free, ja. Eigentlich sollte es an der Stelle alles weggeschmissen werden.
Ja, die Community Edition ist free, also das was du brauchst ist im Endeffekt free. Ich
weiß gar nicht so genau, was der Unterschied ist aktuell zwischen Visual Studio Community
und nicht Community. Früher war es mal diese, ich glaube diese Codesave, nee, nee, wie
hieß das? Team Studio, nee, fuck. Diese komische Microsoft Source Code Verwaltung, die eh
keiner verwendet hat, war glaube ich ein paar Code Analyse Sachen sind wohl glaube ich auch
auf Professional festgelegt. Azure Integration ist glaube ich auch nur bei Professional, aber
ansonsten ist das meiste brauchst du davon eh nicht. Wir können ja mal gucken. Community
Professional. There is no difference between Community or Professional when using Unity
Engine. Ok, wir wollen nicht Unity. Compare Visual Studio Offerings. Ok, guck mal was
da. Usage Scenarios, Enterprise, was auch immer sich dahinter verbirgt, man weiß es
nicht. Ach nett Cody, das Geflame gegen Unity finde ich unberechtigt. Das sind die Spieleentwickler,
die kacke entwickeln und nicht Unity. Das ist genauso wie mit Java, über Java mache
ich mich auch immer gerne lustig und man kann auch in Java viele ordentliche Software programmieren.
Sir of Jelly, da würde ich komplett unterschiedliche Sachen für verwenden. Java in Visual Studio
ist nicht so tolle. Python in Visual Studio geht mittlerweile zwar, aber hält sich in
Grenzen. C geht wahrscheinlich auch, aber gibt es wahrscheinlich auch besseres. Also
Visual Studio würde ich eigentlich nur verwenden für Winners Anwendungen, also sprich F Sharp,
C Sharp. Was geht denn noch schön in Visual Studio? Die Microsoft C++ Geschichten. Mittlerweile
geht glaube ich auch JavaScript ganz gut. VB, genau, Visual Basic habe ich ja komplett
vergessen, falls es heute noch jemand verwendet überhaupt. Verwendet jemand noch Visual Basic?
Golang und Ruby, echt? Geht nicht gut in Visual Studio. Also ich habe mal vor ein paar Jahren
versucht Ruby in Visual Studio zu programmieren, das war nicht schön. Ja PyCharm ist gut.
Ihoden Rakete verwendet VBA, ja das wundert mich nicht bei dem Namen. Mit VBA das geht
ab wie Rakete, aber. VBA, weiß gar nicht welche Software heute noch VBA, aber Excel, Excel
verwendet vor allem VBA. Und jetzt ganze Office, ganze Office gedönnt, oder? Ganze Office gedönnt
ist glaube ich noch VBA. Access Formulare, oh alter. Access Formulare. Ich verwende keine
Access Formulare, ich verwende nur CSV. CSV, Master Race, beste. Visual Basic ist doch
eh genau gleich wie C Sharp, nur dass man statt Klammern eben Then und End If benutzt. Genau.
Viele Sachen, viele neueren Features, die sie jetzt da entwickeln bei Microsoft. Es
ist ja nicht mehr direkt gesyncht, C Sharp Version und.NET Release, aber C Sharp kriegt
eindeutig mehr Liebe als Visual Studio. Und ein paar Sachen, ich hab sogar letztes Mal
in irgendeinem Webcast da drüber gesehen, sind bis heute nicht in Visual Basic angekommen.
Unter der Haube, was da als IL Code rausfällt, das dürfte ziemlich das gleiche sein. Arbeiten
die überhaupt noch an VB.NET? Sie haben nie das Gegenteil behauptet. Wahrscheinlich so
ein bisschen wie bei Windows Phone. Ok, also was erzählt es? Live Dependency Validation.
Ok, ich weiß nicht mal was es ist, deswegen geh ich mal voll aus, ich brauch das nicht.
Das ist Live Dependency Validation. Azure, Azure DevOps Lab. Ok, Azure Zeug, das brauch
ich schon mal nicht. Ich muss übrigens noch, Leute, wir müssen noch ein bisschen was in
Azure machen, fällt mir gerade ein, in einem der nächsten Streams so ein bisschen in Azure
herumklicken, weil ich hab noch 90 Euro auf meinem Azure Account drauf und es verfällt
in 11 Tagen. Da müssen wir noch ein bisschen, da legen wir uns mal ne 120 Core Kiste an
Azure und lassen die 2 Sekunden laufen, dann ist das Geld all. Hast du nicht auch noch
Geld auf Fiverr? Doch, 120 Euro oder so, weil die alle abgesagt haben. Ah, also gth44,
was ist es überhaupt? Ich kann mir da überhaupt nichts darunter vorstellen. Live, also man
kann Live irgendwelche Abhängigkeiten überprüfen, was sagt uns das? Keine Ahnung. Ok, man kann
irgendwelche Diagramme erstellen, das brauch ich auf jeden Fall nicht. Das Design irgendwie,
den Aufbau irgendwie überprüfen, was auch immer es ist, keine Ahnung. Code Clone, auch
keine Ahnung, was das sein soll. Code Lens, das kenn ich, das ist so ein Code Analyzer
von Microsoft, der dir dann teilweise sagt, hier an der Stelle ist per Style Guide, keine
Ahnung, ein Simikolon vorgesehen oder eine Komma oder irgendwie man schreibt die Ifs
am Anfang und nicht am Ende oder irgendwie sowas, das glaube ich Code Lens. Übrigens
Leute hier, was auch witzig ist, was komisch ist, Rishel Studio hier, ach nee, es ist auch
nicht wirklich schneller, die haben irgendwas mit der aktuellen Version gemacht, die haben
irgendwas mit der aktuellen Version gemacht, dass, nee hier gehts, hier gehts. Auf meinem
Main Account ist die Autovervollständigung so übertrieben langsam geworden, ich weiß
gar nicht woran das liegt und ich hab schon den ganzen, bis der standardmäßig dabei
ist, deaktiviert. Weiß ich gar nicht woran das liegt, warum mein Main Account so langsam
ist. So, wir wollen ja noch gucken, was der Unterschied ist. Peak Definition, ja gut,
das geht bei allem. Advanced Debugging, Konsole, beste. Intellitrace, ich hab aber, nee, noch
nicht mal, Rishel ist alles aus auf meinem Main Account, also Main Windows Account, aber
da leckt IntelliSense übelst rum. Ey, meine tollen Funktionsnamen, Leute, ich hab das
in zwei Stunden, bevor ich jetzt, ich bin direkt danach angegangen, als es halbwegs
funktioniert hat, den Kram hier zusammen gewurstet, ja, was man machen können. Kann
ich mir jetzt nicht auch noch tolle Funktionsnamen überlegen, weil. Code Map Debugger Integration.
Source Map kenne ich, weiß nicht, was ein Code Map ist. Der Antivirus, das könnte sein,
wobei ich Windows Defender sowohl hier als auch auf dem anderen habe, aber das könnte
sein. Vielleicht muss ich einfach nur mal den Windows Trick machen und Rishel Studio
deinstallieren und neu installieren. Das hilft bestimmt..NET Core Memory, okay, das
brauche ich, das habe ich zum Glück noch nie gebraucht. Code Matrix. Snapshot Debugger,
Time Travel Debugging. Alter, das liest sich mal absolut next level. Time Travel Debugging.
Wie darf man sich das vorstellen? Zurück in die Zukunft mäßig, oder was? IntelliTest,
weiß ich auch nicht, was es ist. Live Unit Testing, kann man dann der Qt Chat dabei zugucken,
wie die Tests durchlaufen. Cross Platform. Samarien brauche ich nicht. Also, man sieht,
was fehlt an Rishel Studio Community zu Enterprise ist nicht wirklich wichtig. Ich muss mir
das aber in Ruhe noch mal ein bisschen überlegen, wie wir das machen mit dem Schreiben in die
Datenbank beziehungsweise das Updaten und Lesen. Das ist, so wie ich es jetzt zusammen
gewusstet habe, auf jeden Fall nicht der Weisheiterschluss. Wir nehmen lieber doch eine Data Table und
wir nehmen irgendwas, wo man nicht laufend Refresh aufrufen muss, sondern was automatisch
checkt, bin refreshed und so. Mal gucken. Aber was ich immer noch nicht ganz checke ist,
warum der hier, das hat damit nichts zu tun, warum der hier die Sachen nicht updatet.
Sollte er hier eigentlich die Sachen updaten? Das gucken wir uns jetzt gleich schon mal an.
Bloop Chat. Fügen wir ein paar Dinge hinzu. Saven, gesaved. Und jetzt sollte er die eigentlich
auslegen. Kann das? Passt. Ok. Order. Items. Drei. Passt doch. Warum macht er das nicht?
Aber der macht prinzipiell schon das Richtige. Aber hier refresht er den Kram nicht. Warum
denn das nicht? Der müsste das doch refreshen. Warum refresht er das nicht? Warum refresht
er das nur beim adden? Ok, ne, das ist irgendwie von der Logik her von Arsch. Bezahl einfach
wen auf Fiverr. Alter, auf Fiverr, die haben mir noch nicht mal einen Twitch Chatlogger
hingekriegt. Den Controls gescheite Namen geben, ja. BattleLP Twitch Prime, Dankeschön. Irgendwie
das hier rum. Er saved das? Der data das doch richtig. Xdafuck Twitch Prime. Dankeschön,
nice. Big Brain. Wie ist denn das? Ist das irgendeine EF Core Geschichte vielleicht?
Dass man. Na gut. Ok, ich muss mal was eintragen, was ich auch wieder finde. Ähm. Ist das
vielleicht eine EF Core Geschichte? Dass der die Sachen nicht löscht? Als Abhängigkeit
dann könnte das sein. Also wir haben jetzt ja nachgeguckt, dass das löschen prinzipiell
richtig funktioniert. So, Moment, äh, mach das nochmal zu. Wir benennen das jetzt mal
so, dass ich, dass ich's finde hier. Keine Ahnung. Äh, hallo. Hallo und dann fügen wir
hier was hinzu. So, save. Funktioniert. So, wir löschen jetzt alles bis auf drei. Save.
So, und wir haben gerade nachgeguckt. Ähm, das funktioniert. Kann das sein, dass EF Core
das nicht löscht, wenn ich's eben nicht explizit sage? Weil, es ist ja so, ich update hier
zwar die Order, aber was ich gemacht habe sind, ähm, quasi Sachen aus Items löschen.
Muss man, muss man das dem irgendwie explizit sagen, dass er das, dass er das löschen soll?
Aber gucken wir mal. Gucken wir mal mit dem SQL Explorer, was denn, was da hinten jetzt
rausgekommen ist. Borders, hallo, 23. Tatsächlich, der löscht das nicht. Ähm. Muss Max jetzt
das Fiverr Projekt zeigen? Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich da hinkomme. Dann müssen wir uns jetzt
auf Fiverr einloggen, Klei. Ey Leute, wollen wir uns jetzt Fiverr angucken? Fiverr? Da gibt's
aber nicht so viel zu gucken. Okay, da müsst ihr mir jetzt helfen. Da müsst ihr mir erstmal
hier das, das Problem müssen wir jetzt noch fixen und dann gucken wir uns Fiverr an. Also,
das ist irgendeine Konfigurationsgeschichte von mir, weil ich zu smallbrain bin. Ich hab
hier eine Order mit Items drinne. So. Und wenn ich da, wenn ich dort jetzt Items lösche
und sag meiner Datenbank, update mal diese Order, dann löscht er nicht die Items da
raus. Er fügt sie nur hinzu. Was muss ich EF Core sagen, dass der das macht? Da müssen
wir Google fragen. Child Collection. Da, da ist doch hier die Frage. Was? Aha. Okay,
oder löschen oder hinzufügen. Ah, der hat aber Recht, was er hier schreibt. Ich glaube,
daran liegt das, weil meine Order, glaube ich, weiß woran das liegt. Meine Order setze
ich, setze ich hier. Die kommt nicht, die kommt nicht aus dem, aus dem DB-Kontext und
dementsprechend trackt er auch meine Changes nicht. Das heißt, wenn ich will, dass das
funktioniert, wenn ich will, dass es funktioniert, muss ich das Ganze hier nochmal irgendwie
aus dem DB-Kontext laden oder so und dann löschen. Und dann wird es wahrscheinlich
funktionieren. So. Das kommt nicht aus dem Change-Tracker hier beziehungsweise nicht
aus dem DB-Kontext. Attach-Method. Aha. Nee. Geht das Attach?
So. Kann man das, kann man das einfach so?
Kann man das einfach so machen? Nee, oder? Kann man nicht einfach so machen, oder? Das
funktioniert bestimmt nicht. Nee, nee, nee, funktioniert so nicht. Sehr gut, dann muss
ich mir das nochmal in Ruhe überlegen. Oder gucken wir uns jetzt gleich Fiverr an, würde
ich sagen. Ich muss gucken, dass das, ich muss, ich muss das mit, ich muss das anders
machen. Ich weiß, ich weiß, wie ich das machen muss. Und zwar ich übergebe hier nicht die
Order, sondern ich übergebe die Order-ID und lade mir den Kram dann, ja, und lade mir
dann den Kram raus aus dem, aus dem, aus dem DB-Kontext. Müsste ich, das müsste ich hier
eigentlich machen. Irgendwie so. Da muss ich mal gucken. Wollte mal gucken, wie wir das
machen. Okay, also gucken wir uns mal Fiverr an. Wir sind ja schon wieder eine Weile on,
ne? Nachdem ich da schon mal zwei Stunden am Stück vorher das Ding zusammen gewurstet
hab. Ja, also. Dann loggen wir uns mal ein auf Fiverr. Ich muss, es kann aber sein, dass
ich euch ausstellen muss, weil ich nicht weiß, was ich über Fiverr registriert hab. Hatten
wir nicht das Fiverr Projekt hier schon mal runtergeladen oder so? Ne, ne? Okay, Fiverr,
Fiverr. Also, für alle, die sich mitgekriegt haben, ich habe mal vor einer Weile ein Tool
programmiert für den Twitch-Chat, was einfach den kompletten Twitch-Chat mitschneidet und
schaut, was mich erwähnt. Glaube, das gab es hier. Contains and Wobblers. Ne, das ist
das nicht das Richtige. Das heißt zwar Twitch-Chat, aber das ist nicht das Richtige. Was war das
Richtige? Kurz gucken, wie das wirkt. Boah, jaja. Okay. TestNet3, wirklich Net3 genannt,
natürlich wieder typischer Max-Big-Brain-Name. Das Ding Net3 heißt. Ja, das ist es. Also,
starten. Kostet weiter nicht den Haufen Geld, doch. Ich verwende einfach immer die Lizenz
zum Trial. Okay, ich zeige euch jetzt mal das Tool, was ich dort in Auftrag gegeben
habe. Ich glaube aber, ich habe es kaputt gemacht bei mir. Welcher Port tauscht das
standardmäßig? Steht da irgendetwas da? 5000. Also, so sieht das aus, was ich da gebastelt
habe. Also, im Prinzip, nichts großartig kompliziertes. Ein Tool, was alle Twitch-Chat-Fragen mitloggt,
die an mich gehen, sodass ich keine Fragen mehr übersehe, mit einem Knopf dahinter,
um die Sache zu löschen. Und, das, wie man hier sieht, ist nicht sonderlich viel. Das
sind so 100, 200, so 200, 250 Zeilen inklusive HTML und allem Boilerplate, was man so braucht.
Also, es ist nicht großartig kompliziert und man sieht es hier auch, es ist ziemlich
übersichtlich, was man dafür machen muss. Also, Web-Anwendung und auch das HTML ist
wirklich super easy. Also, sieht man, das sollte für jemanden, der ein bisschen geübt
ist, echt kein großer Akt sein. Will einer Black Ops 1 Key verschenken? Wo es das günstig
gibt? Guck mal, irgendwie bei G2A, Kinguin oder irgendwie so komischen Key-Shops. Also,
es ist nicht sonderlich schwierig. So, und ich bin auf Fiverr gegangen und hab nach den
günstigsten Programmierern gesucht, die versprechen, eine vollständige ASP.NET-Anwendung zu programmieren.
So, ich muss mich jetzt mal einloggen. Fiverr ist eine Plattform, wo du kreative Leute
beauftragen kannst, Dinge für dich zu machen. So, ich muss jetzt erstmal hier kurz gucken,
wie mein Passwort für Fiverr ist. Okay Leute, muss ich mal kurz ausblenden, wenn ich sicher
bin, ob das hier funktioniert. Soll ich mal gucken, ob das auch noch funktioniert.
Okay, don't save. Bin eingeloggt bei Fiverr. Kannst du einen Passwortmanager empfehlen?
Ja, ich verwende immer noch Key-Pass. Seit Jahren schon. Damit fahre ich eigentlich auch
ganz gut. So, also, denk dran, das hier sollte rauskommen. Eine simple Web-Anwendung, die
Chat mitloggt auf Twitch. So, und ich hab mir bei Fiverr Leute rausgesucht. Guck mal,
120 Euro hab ich noch auf Fiverr, weil die alle wieder zurückgezogen haben. Ich ändere
mal den Titel auf Fiverr. So, und ich hab mir Leute rausgesucht. Guck mal, hier Orders.
Cancelled, Cancelled, Cancelled, Cancelled. Messages. Inboard. Wo sind denn die Messages
von den Typen? Ja, also, ich hab mir hier Leute rausgesucht,
wie Ahmed zum Beispiel, der halt gesagt hat, ich programmiere euch eine komplette ASP.NET
Core Web-Applikation, überhaupt kein Problem. Da hab ich ihm halt erklärt, was ich haben
wollte. Und gibt es hier keine ordentlichen Messages-Übersicht eigentlich bei Fiverr oder
nicht? Ah, hier, View All Orders. Da, jetzt kann ich es euch zeigen. Completed. Genau,
und hab ich ihm beschrieben, was ich haben will. Nämlich halt sowas hier. Im Prinzip
eine Web-Anwendung, die sie bauen können, wie sie wollen, was sie dafür verwenden, ist
mir eigentlich egal. Hauptsache sie verwenden ASP.NET Core im Backend, weil ich hab mir
halt ASP.NET Core Entwickler rausgesucht und hab ihnen gesagt, hier, mach einfach, mach
einfach, mach wie du willst. Ich will den Tool haben, was Twitch Chat mitguckt, ob ich
angeschrieben werde. Ganz einfach. So, es haben von 11 Leute, die ich angeschrieben
habe, haben 10 Leute gecancelt. Ich mein, ich kanns verstehen. Ich würde das für 6,67
Euro auch nicht machen. Also ich würde den Rechner für 6,67 Euro noch nicht mal hochfahren.
Dafür. Ich kann verstehen, dass sie alle abgesagt haben. Aber sie haben alle in ihrem Profil
drinstehen, dass sie sowas machen. Und wer reinschreibt, dass man für 6,67 Euro any
kind of ASP.NET MVC or Core Application developed, dann sollte man es vielleicht nicht reinschreiben.
Aber es steht halt drin. Ja, es ist im Prinzip viel heiße Luft und nichts dahinter. Zumindest
haben die alle abgesagt. Der eine war richtig cool. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, welcher das
gewesen ist. War das der hier? Nein. War das der hier? Nein, das war der hier. Nein, das
war der hier. Okay, der hat gleich gecancelt. Der hier, genau. Ich hab denen übrigens auch
allen einen Hinweis gegeben. Ich hab denen den Hinweis gegeben, wenn sie nicht weiter
wussten. Wobei ich eigentlich ganz ehrlich davon ausgegangen wäre, dass ein guter Programmierer
das selber rauskriegt. Ich hab denen alle noch den Hinweis gegeben, dass soweit ich
weiß, Twitch einen IRC Chat anbietet, den man anonym benutzen kann. Das hab ich allen,
die gesagt haben, sie wissen nicht genau, was ich will, was ich mach. Das hab ich denen
allen gesagt, weil ich hatte das Gefühl, es hat da keiner so richtig gecheckt, wie er
das machen soll. Der Typ hier war eh geil. Ich hab ihm gesagt, ich geb ihm sogar noch
Trinkgeld, wenn er's extra macht. Und jetzt kommt halt die Frage, how much is your budget?
Er hat's für 11,43 Euro reingestellt. Dann hab ich gesagt, 50 Euro maximal. Und der andere
kommt, ich will 700 Euro. Der will's wissen. No. Das ist schon geil, ne? Lass mal halt
so Dinger reinschreiben. Mal gucken, was mittlerweile im Profil steht. Sein Profil geupdatet.
Ach, guck mal. Das gibt's überhaupt nicht mehr. Das ist was anderes. Der hat jetzt
sein Profil geupdatet. Ich mein, aber komm. I will create a custom web solution for your
business needs. Da kann man das schon drunter vorstellen. Single page application. Er hat
alles reingeschrieben, was man braucht. So, 9,40 Euro. Und dann will er 700 Euro. Bam,
in your face. Ich hab denen aber übrigens alle keinen Stress gemacht. So was erlaubt
wahrscheinlich nicht. Wahrscheinlich ist es auch gegen die Pfeiffer-Regeln, aber ich
mein, okay, erst. Und ich hab ja halt gesagt, okay, übrigens mein Name ist der beste. Ich
heiße Max Lull, aber stelle mich immer als Peter Lull vor. Als Peter Lull oder Peter
Wubblords oder irgendwie so. Ja, hier sind die Project Specification. Naja, also das
war, das kam viele, die sowas geschrieben haben. Gab viele, die sowas geschrieben haben,
dass sie das nicht für die Kohle machen. Und ich mein, guck mal, ich bin der Ansicht,
ich bin ihm schon ziemlich entgegengekommen. Ich hab ihm gesagt, okay, 11,43 Euro sehe
ich ein. 50 Euro ist okay. Und dann immer noch nicht. Ich würds für diesen Preis natürlich
auch nicht machen. Aber dann sollen wir es halt nicht reinschreiben. So, und das ging
mit allen so ein bisschen hin und her. Und der Einzige, der was geliefert hat am Ende,
für wie viel hättest du sowas gemacht? Das eigentliche Machen ist gar nicht so, gar
nicht so das Problem. Es ist ja, warum es für schwierig fällt, das einzuschätzen ist,
ich hab im Vorfeld halt ne Weile auch geguckt, wie man das am besten machen kann. Deswegen
hab ich denen auch alle den Hinweis auf den IRC-Chat gegeben. Keine Ahnung. Sind wir die
Frage, ob auch noch dann anschließend Support irgendwie mit dabei ist oder noch extra Wünsche
oder so. Aber ich sag mal so, was in dem Umfang, was ich hier zusammen gewurstet hab, ich kauf
für, keine Ahnung, 200 Euro oder so. 200 Euro, 300 Euro, 200 bis 300 Euro wär ich
dir wahrscheinlich zufrieden mit. Irgendwie soll man Daumen gepeilt werden. Natürlich
würd ichs da ein bisschen schöner machen als nur für mich. So, aber 700 ist ein bisschen
viel. Mal ganz davon abgesehen, kann man das nicht so wirklich vergleichen, weil, das
sind ja halt zum größten Teil Inder oder irgendwo aus dieser Ecke, wie man das auch
an den Namen sieht. Und da siehts ja mit Kohle noch mal anders aus. Deswegen können die
ja auch die Sachen so billig anbieten. Naja, zumindest der einzige, der geliefert hat,
ist Develop WordPresser. Okay, der hat sein Profil mittlerweile geändert. Ja, der einzige,
der den Auftrag erledigt hat, ist Umasharik2. Der hat auch ein bisschen rumgewurstet. Blablabla,
die haben hier all looks fine. Soll Peter Lull enthalten. Okay, und er hat mir das Ganze,
den Source Code hat er mir geschickt als Ra-File. Auch schonmal geil. Twitch.ra, deswegen lad ich
das jetzt auch nur unter Linux runter. Ich mein, verschickt ihr eure Aufträge beziehungsweise
euren Source Code. Ich auch immer per Ra-File. Der andere Seite, was soll er großartig machen?
Ich meine, er hätte mir einen Link zu irgendeinem Repo schicken können, aber er hat seine Seite
mittlerweile geändert, dass er kein, dass er kein, dass er, er macht kein ASP.NET mehr,
macht das nur WordPress. So, okay. Jetzt gucken wir uns mal den Code an, den er gebastelt hat.
Unra, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das installiert hab. Twitch. Ach so, wie geht das? X. So, und das
ist das, was er programmiert hat. Wir müssen dazu sagen, ich muss dazu sagen, ich hab schonmal
reingeguckt und da waren ein paar sehr abenteuerliche Sachen dabei. Wenn ihr wollt, können wir uns
später auch noch die anderen angucken, was sie so geschrieben haben. Ich versuchte ein bisschen,
bisschen mehr Geld aus den Rippen zu leiern. Okay, machen wir das Ganze mal auf. Ups. Oder?
Hat er eigentlich, hat das jetzt eigentlich aktualisiert? Den Titel? Für euch? Vom Streben?
Ja, okay, nice. Ups. Ups. Hat es jetzt funktioniert? Ja, hat funktioniert. Perfekt.
Also, gucken wir uns mal an, was er programmiert hat. Wo fangen wir denn am besten an? Program
CS. Das ist Default, da hat er nichts drinne gemacht. Also, das ist ein ganz normales ASP.NET Core,
wie soll ich sagen, Standard Template. Assassin of Fivehead, richtig Fivehead. Big Brain. Also,
da hat er nix schonmal drinne gemacht, da müssen wir mal schauen. Oh fuck, mein Twitch-Vorschau-Browser
ist gerade übelst abgekackt. Was ist da los? Warum ist das kaputt? Leute, Chat, jetzt benehmt euch,
ich seh den Chat grad nicht mehr. So, mein Chat ist wieder da. Okay. BattleLP und Xdafuck. Danke
für, geiler Name, für den Sub. Hab ich glaube ich übersehen. So, okay, gucken wir mal, was er hat. Okay, also das ist Standard Default-Things.
Standard, hat er hier was drinne gemacht? Nein, das ist auch Standard Template. Standard ASP.NET Core Template,
da hat er nix drinne gemacht. Das ist auch Standard. Bootstrap, JavaScript, hat er da was gemacht? Nein.
CSS, das ist auch Default. Wo hat er denn überhaupt was gemacht? Twitch, das ist von ihm wahrscheinlich.
ISC-Chant.CSHTML, Razorpage. Okay, also, big brain code, gucken wir uns jetzt mal an. Also, was macht er hier?
Es sind irgendwelche Razorpages. Model. Twitch Chat, Twitch, okay, die Models müssen wir uns auch nochmal angucken. Twitch View Model.
Username Channel. Okay, das hält sich in Grenzen. Einheitlich, ob groß oder klein schreiben, ist auch nicht angesagt.
Also, man merkt, ist das ASP.NET, ja, ist das, ist das, also man merkt, dass er wahnsinnig Bock hat auf das ganze Projekt.
Lemonv7, Dankeschön. Okay, gucken wir uns mal an, was er hier getrieben hat. Was, was genau soll mir das hier sagen?
Darf man das so nicht machen? Okay, also, das ist eine Razorpage mit diesem Model. Dann ein bisschen HTML.
Er zeigt den Username an. Machst du ein Code Review? Naja, ich habe, also, STBA42, ich habe bei Fiverr ein paar Sachen in Auftrag gegeben.
Und gucke jetzt, was rausgekommen ist. Zeig doch erstmal das Programm. Nee, ich fühle das nicht einfach aus, ohne mir angeguckt zu haben, was da drinnen steht.
Glaubst du doch selbst nicht, dass ich das einfach mal ausführe, ohne reingeguckt zu haben. Das hier ist, glaube ich, echt big brain.
Guck mal. Item in Model Take One? For each in Take What? Das habe ich schon mal gesehen, das habe ich, das habe ich mir, das ist die einzige Zeile, die ich mir schon mal angeguckt habe oder, oder, oder mir in Erinnerung geblieben ist von der ganzen, was ist das?
Hat das irgendeinen Sinn? Versteht das einer? Warum? Also, ich meine, das ist eine Schleife, ja, ich, ich weiß, was es macht, aber ich versuche mich gerade rein zu denken, warum man das so macht.
Also, ich meine, es ist eine Schleife über einen IEnumerable. Allerdings ist da immer nur ein Item drin. Hätte er nicht einfach Model nehmen können oder, oder einfach, oder einfach Model 1 oder Model First oder Model First or Default hätte er nehmen können oder sowas?
Das einzige, äh, Patrick weiß ich nicht mehr, das einzige, was mir hier zu einfällt ist, so wird das nicht ausgeführt, wenn in Model, wenn keine Models drin sind, aber da hätte man einfach auch einen If machen können.
Also, das ist, das ist schon ein bisschen sehr um die Ecke. Eine Vorschleife über, über ein Element, anstatt das Element direkt zu verwenden.
So, und das ist JustinFan12345, okay, daco, SplitItBaby, die besten Kommentare ever, SplitItBaby.
Was macht der denn hier? Document Get Element By ID Content. Okay, Inner, InnerHTML, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt replace da irgendwelche Farben oder so.
Picsing a bit to string, string, der bastelt irgendwelche HTML Geschichten zusammen, ähm, okay, er macht irgendwelche Magic für sein HTML, jetzt macht er SplitItBaby, ähm, und jetzt guckt er, ob das ganze rot ist.
Und wenn es nicht rot ist, färbt er es rot. Wenn ich das jetzt so richtig, richtig interpretiere.
Der färbt meinen Namen rot, der färbt meinen Namen rot, allerdings hat er nicht verstanden, was ich haben will, allerdings hat er nicht verstanden, was ich haben will, er soll nicht den Namen JustinFan rot färben, sondern er soll Peter0, wie ich eben auf Fiverr heiße, rot färben.
JustinFan brauche nur für den Twitch Chat IRC, nicht für das Webfrontend. Also von der Funktion her ist es schonmal falsch, das macht nicht das, was ich haben wollte.
Ähm, okay, was haben wir da als nächstes? Controller, was ist denn im Controller drin? Der Twitch Controller. Socket? IRC-Chat? Ach nee, das hat er einfach generiert.
Okay, er macht hier nichts. Das hier, das hier ist die eigentliche Sache, das hier ist die eigentliche Sache, die, ähm, die man braucht, um sich zu dem Twitch IRC zu connecten.
Und wisst ihr was das lustige ist? Das ist eins zu eins der Python-Code, den ich ihm geschickt habe. Das ist noch nicht mal eine eigene Leistung gewesen, das hier auch da drauf zu kommen, weil was ich euch jetzt gar nicht gezeigt habe ist, in dem Auftrag habe ich ihm erklärt, wie es geht.
Ich hab ihm mit dem Auftrag erklärt, wie es funktioniert, ähm, und hab ihm, ich hab ihm, ich hab ihm, ich hab ihm, ich hab ihm Python-Sample-Code geschickt, wie es funktioniert.
Und er hat einfach nur den Python-Sample-Code genommen und hat das halbwegs lauffähig gemacht in, in.NET. So.
Was aber okay ist. Was aber okay ist. Da hab ich, da hab ich überhaupt keine Schmerzen mit. Es ist natürlich ein bisschen blöd, dass ich's ihm raussuchen musste.
Ja, ich hab ihm fünfmal versucht zu erklären, um was es geht, ähm, aber wie gesagt, der Einzige, der's gemacht hat. So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal an, ob das hier überhaupt theoretisch funktioniert, was er da, was er da gebastelt hat.
Also ganz ehrlich, wenn ich einfach nur ein normaler Typ auf Twitch wäre, der sowas haben möchte und es nicht vorher selbst programmiert hätte, ich hätte ihm garantiert nicht einen Link zu einem GitHub-Projekt schicken können, wo das eine an Python schonmal gebastelt hat.
Die variablen Benamungen sind auch absolut Kraut und Rüben, ne?
IP.
Werden die Leute eigentlich geprüft mit Testaufgaben? Nö.
Ich glaube, was er versucht zu machen oder was der, das ist im Prinzip, also ich zeige euch mal zum Vergleich, wie es bei mir ausschaut, wie meine Sache aussieht. Wo kann man hier nochmal Projekte aufmachen?
Ja. Also mal zum Vergleich. Meine Geschichte sieht so aus. Da sieht man, es ist eigentlich relativ ähnlich, nur kann man diesen Shit da mal ausblenden.
Also, das ist, das sind die vergleichbaren Sachen von mir. Und das ist was Base64 encode.
War das überhaupt? Mach ich doch an der Stelle auch nicht. Um eins funktioniert er. Base64 encode?
Brauch beizen, wusste nicht, wie sonst, ich weiß nicht. Aber ich bilde mir an, man muss irgendwas mit Base64 machen. Encode ich das irgendwo? Base64 hier, seht ihr was?
Ich bin erstaunt, dass das funktioniert. Ich bin erstaunt, dass das funktioniert.
Der schickte Base64 encode das rüber, wo man eigentlich UTF-8 bytes schicken sollte. Ob das funktioniert? Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher.
Okay. Das macht gar kein Base64 encode. Das heißt nur Base64 encode.
Das ist gar kein Base64 encode. Das ist Chibate.
Okay, das ist das Highlight. Das ist echt nice. Base64 encode. Okay, also wir haben uns das jetzt angeguckt. Das sollte nichts Schlimmes machen. Wir führen das Ganze jetzt einfach mal aus und gucken, ob es überhaupt funktioniert.
Wir gucken, ob es überhaupt funktioniert.
Das bildet schon mal ganz schön lange. Ach fuck, ich kack Noob. Wenn man Exit macht, exited ja alles. Und nicht nur das eine Fenster. Ich hätte Exit-Window oder Close-Window oder so machen müssen.
Big brain plays, Leute.
Okay, auf geht's starten.
Warum bildet das eigentlich so ewig?
Wird jetzt der indische Keylogger ausgeführt oder was?
Falsche Framework-Version, okay. Wollen wir das Settings umstellen?
Ach, das ist noch.NET Core 3 Review. Aber trotzdem, man sollte doch mit.NET Core auch ohne Probleme ASP.NET Links 2 ausführen können. Wahrscheinlich braucht das Blazer Zeug, da ist doch kein Blazer dabei.
Das ist jetzt 2er.
Das ist jetzt das 2er.NET. Wir gucken, ob es damit funktioniert.
Wow. Okay, ich glaube, ich muss nochmal neu starten. Das packt gerade rum.
Damit müsste es jetzt aber funktionieren. Es läuft, okay.
Also, hier ist es. Hier ist es. Username.
Das verwende er doch nie, oder?
Ich glaube, Username verwende er doch nie.
Was muss ich denn wo eingeben? Channel? Okay. Channel? Wo Blots?
Username? Keine Ahnung, Search.
Ich sag doch, es funktioniert, oder? Was ist das?
Funktioniert nicht. Username? So?
Nope. Es geht nicht. Es ist kaputt.
Oder muss ich hier Justin Fan irgendwie reinschreiben?
Tatsächlich. Okay, das macht überhaupt nicht das, was ich haben wollte.
Automatisch updaten tut es auch nicht, oder?
Also, wirklich funktioniert tut das Ganze nicht. Nee, das funktioniert nicht.
Es ist kaputt, was er in der programmiert hat.
Aber Justin Fan ist rot, ja. Yeah.
Wie war nochmal die Anforderungsbeschreibung dazu? Moment, kann ich dir zeigen?
Ich hab sie mir danach ausführlich erklärt.
Er hat sogar sich den Twitch-Chat angeguckt und festgestellt, dass ich dann...
Alter, Piver, geh mal nicht auf den Sack.
Good Programmer, nice communication.
Auftrag, Requirements. Ja.
Wine? Warum zum Teufel sollte ich jetzt in Wine öffnen wollen?
Ich will das in Firefox aufmachen.
Wine? Alter, warum startest du Wine, um den PDF zu öffnen?
What the fuck?
Lullen, Alter.
Okay, kann aber einfach so. Warum macht er das nicht einfach im Browser auf?
Jetzt macht er es im Browser auf. Big brain, next level, Wahnsinn.
Das hab ich ihm geschrieben, ja.
Also nicht Justin Fan.
Wine ist quasi eine Windows-AP-Implementierung für Linux.
Das hat er auch gemacht.
Dann hab ich ihm gesagt, ich will nicht, dass das Ding einen AP-Key braucht.
Das hab ich reingeschrieben, weil ich die Leute dazu bringen wollte festzustellen,
ah ja, es gibt ja eine IRC-AP, aber da hätten sie mal selbst nachgucken müssen.
Channel und Username sollte man einstellen können.
Allerdings, wie gesagt, der Channel, den ich überwachen will und nicht Justin Fan.
Ich lass mal laufen, vielleicht geht's ja nach, ups, vielleicht geht's ja jetzt nach einer Weile.
Justin Fan.
Funktioniert das überhaupt? Geht der überhaupt in den richtigen Channel rein?
Was der da gebastelt hat, geht der überhaupt in den richtigen?
Vor allem, warum ist das denn ein Controller?
Das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Das funktioniert überhaupt nicht.
Guck mal, das müsste eine Endlosschleife sein, die im Hintergrund läuft.
Die hat erstens in dem Controller nichts zu suchen, der lockt sich einfach nur ein und...
Alter, das ist ja noch weniger das, was ich haben wollte als...
Oh man.
So, ich hab gesagt, Chat-Messages sollen einen Neustart überstehen, machen sie nicht.
Und ich hätte gerne einen Knopf, um Chat-Nachrichten zu löschen, der ist auch nicht da.
Schluss, das Frontend soll sich selbst refreshen, wenn eine neue Nachricht ankommt.
Und das soll Zeit und Datum anzeigen, wann sie gepostet werden. Fertig.
Ich finde, die Beschreibung ist verständlich, oder?
Und wenn nicht, kann man an zwei, drei Stellen nachfragen und man versteht es wieder.
Oder, der hätte mich ein paar Sachen spezifisch nachfragen können und hätte das eigentlich verstehen müssen, oder?
Ich finde, man kann das recht gut erkennen.
Der hat jetzt echt den Wine geöffnet, ich fass es nicht.
Ja, also...
Es funktioniert nicht wirklich.
Ich bin schon wieder auf dem Weg.
Jetzt habt ihr das Fiverr Programm gesehen von dem Einzigen, der geantwortet hat.
Also der Einzige, der eine Lösung erarbeitet hat.
Wobei das keine wirkliche Lösung ist.
Ach stimmt, da hat der Videos gesteht
Ja er hat das gleiche
Ja Fiverr ist jetzt gut
Er hat mir ein Bild davon geschickt
Was er macht
Macht man das Bild
Macht man das Bild wieder zu
Checkt die Fiverr Seite nicht
Wie viel habe ich ihm gegeben 36 Dollar
36 Dollar immerhin
Okay gucken wir uns mal das Video an
Alter was geht mit der Aufnahme
Das ist halt absolut nicht das was ich haben wollte
Wie macht man den Scheiß hier zu überhaupt
Escape geht nicht
Das da
Versuch mal Wupplos
Sehr gute Big Prane Idee
Big Prane
Justin Fan 1,2,3
So
Ja aber das kann nicht funktionieren
Er macht ja gar keine Hintergrundschleife
Also er macht nichts im Background
Und er macht es auch gleich wieder zu
Was macht das Programm dann
Ja um ehrlich zu sein macht es nicht sonderlich viel von ihm
Das einzige was es macht ist
Es meldet sich einmal im Twitch IRC Chat an
Kriegt die Willkommensmeldung
Und meldet sich und macht danach gleich wieder gleich wieder zu
Und es färbt lustigerweise auch nur Justin Fan 1,2,3,4,5 ein
Oh Gott ist das Fail
Weil wenn ich mich Justin Fan 1,2,3,4,5 nenne
Dann funktioniert zumindest das Highlighten vom Username
Jede andere Justin Fan Geschichte geht nicht
Bewertet den mal entsprechend
Ich hab den schon bewertet
Ich hab reingeschrieben ganz toller Programmierer
Ich will denen mit meinem Zeug keine
Keine irgendwie
Da es irgendwie von Fiverr kicken oder so
Es ist egal es war ein Versuch
Und mir war klar
Dass man für 5 Euro oder 7 Euro indische Programmierer jetzt nichts
Wirklich richtig ausgereiftes erwarten kann
Das Farben Splitted Baby hat auch nicht so funktioniert
Ja
Okay also
Das ist die Qualität von Fiverr
Man bestellt was
Einer gibt was ab was absolut nicht das tut was es tun soll
11 sagen ab
Und von diesen 10 sagen ab
Und von diesen 10
Achso wollen wir uns das aktuelle Profil von ihm nochmal angucken
Und von diesen 10 wollten eigentlich auch über die Hälfte viel viel viel mehr Geld
Wir gucken mal was er jetzt macht
WordPress Website und Bugfix WordPress
Er hat ASP.NET Core rausgenommen
Ob ich mit für verantwortlich bin
Dass er ASP.NET rausgenommen hat
War die Aufgabe so komplex oder unsichtig
Nein
War sie nicht
Also Leute ihr habt ihr wart ja vielleicht ein paar in dem Stream dabei wo wir das zusammen programmiert haben
Das gepaart mit meiner Beschreibung
Da hätte man doch eigentlich wenn man halbwegs weiß was man macht
Ein bisschen weiter kommen müssen als so oder
Bin ich dazu anspruchsvoll
Aber wir wollen jetzt hier nicht zu sehr flamen
Weil er hat immerhin sich dran gewagt
So und die anderen cancelt
Den einen haben wir uns ja schon mal angeguckt
Die anderen lohnen sich gar nicht großartig anzugucken
Die haben das UI sieht hübsch aus das UI ist Standard Bootstrap aus dem ASP.NET Core Template
Was passiert mit den restlichen 120 Euro
Ich weiß ich kann man die sich irgendwie wieder irgendwie wieder zurück überweisen lassen oder so
Okay wir gucken mal
ASMR ASMR Adult ASMR YouTube
Was habe ich da gesucht
Monka Toss
Ich glaube ich habe gesucht ob es Leute gibt für den
Für mein Meme Board
Ob ich nicht ein paar Sprecher finde oder Sprecherinnen die Dinger sagen können
Ich habe gedacht das wäre wahrscheinlich ganz lustig
Aber da gibt es gibt es ja gibt es ist auf Fiverr kannst du kannst du alles kaufen
Also du hast da auch Leute die beispielsweise sagen
I do cute Anime Girls Adult Voiceovers und sowas
Alles dabei
Ja klar
Das lohnt sich nicht das jetzt anzugucken
Die haben alle abgesagt die haben alle abgesagt oder haben gesagt mehr Geld
Das ist alles wirklich gecheckt hat es keiner
Kannst du mal nein das mache ich jetzt hier und stream garantiert nicht
Ja Leute so sah das mit Fiverr aus
Also ich gebe zu
Mein Programm ist jetzt nicht die optische Augenweide was ich hier gebastelt habe
Aber es funktioniert es funktioniert jetzt übrigens gerade nicht weil ich es ausgemacht habe
Aber es funktioniert
Einfacher Weg um in Chrome die IP zu verschleiern
VPN
Kannst auch eine komischen China Proxy oder so nehmen aber VPN ist das beste
Oh I'm not trolling Fiverr's
They want more money
They advertised service for
5 to 15 euros and 1700
Bangladesh hat bessere loading time
Na ja gut so sah es aus
So sah es aus mit Fiverr
War es eigentlich
Deswegen habe ich da auch deswegen habe ich da auch noch kein Video zugemacht
Weil was was soll ich da groß im Video zu erzählen
Hast du Bock dir das Github von der NSA anzugucken
Weil die NSA hat ein Github
Gibt es auf Fiverr keine Programmierpros doch doch auf jeden Fall
Auf jeden Fall und es gäbe auch garantiert auf Fiverr
Genug die das machen könnten
Aber ich wollte halt absichtlich welche probieren die explizit sagen
Wir für für 5 bis 15 Euro machen wir das
Der BND hat auch eine Github ja
Die haben auf Github haben die so eine Reverse Engineer Challenge mal gehabt
Ja Leute
Gibt es noch irgendwas was wir machen können
Ich glaube ich log jetzt um und spiele eine Runde
Ich wollte gerade sagen Overwatch mache ich nicht
Eine Runde Borderlands weiter
Ich muss sagen das Borderlands Endgame ist gar nicht mal so übel
Da kann er ganz schön noch ein bisschen vor sich hin brinden
Omas Märchenstunde live die Marmeladenoma ist online
Könnten wir hosten
Die habe ich mir irgendwann abonniert als das bei Kronk gezeigt wurde
Da habe ich mir gedacht sowas muss man eigentlich unterstützen
Overwatch ja ich habe die Role Queue mal ausprobieren
Ich habe mich nach den ersten zwei Games schon wieder so aufgeregt
Dass ich direkt rage quitted bin
Ich glaube ich habe es auch gar nicht mehr installiert
Borderlands ist ein Entspannungs Game für mich
Ich log jetzt um wir sehen uns morgen früh
Sonntag früh ist immer Aufwach Stream
Falls der ein oder andere noch nicht weiß wohin mit seinem Twitch Prime Sub
Ihr wisst ja und Big IQ haben wollt dann seid ihr hier richtig
Und wie gesagt spätestens morgen früh sehen wir uns
Ich werde dann nachmittags mal gucken dass ich den restlichen Krams hier vom Hardware Rad tue
Was ich da heute zwei Stunden zusammen geklotzt habe
Welche Uhrzeit immer so von zwischen neun und zehn so in dem Dreh geht es immer los oder
Manchmal auch nach zehn aber von neun bis zehn Uhr dreißig in dem Dreh geht es immer los
Und dann so bis 13 Uhr wir haben glaube ich sogar schon bis 14 14 30 oder so
Ich spiele jetzt kein Overwatch ganz bestimmt nicht ganz bestimmt nicht
Du kannst mir das mal schicken wir können das mal ausprobieren
Aber jetzt nicht on Stream jetzt ich log jetzt um und spiele ein bisschen Borderlands oder irgendwas oder gucke irgendwas bei Amazon
Max DPS tot zumindest Overwatch
Ich hab das ja eigentlich den Channel damals nur gemacht weil ich halt Bock hatte
Overwatch sehr Overwatch spezifische Videos zu machen
Und das Problem war dann nur dass mir Overwatch eine Woche nachdem ich den Channel aufgemacht habe
Keinen Bock mehr hatte keinen Bock mehr gemacht hat
Nächste Woche schon MW ja ja glaube schon nächste Woche Freitag glaube ich
Okay Leute also bis denn macht's gut